Oh ich habe Qualitätsoptionen.
Das ist ja nice.
Gleich beim ersten war es Twitch Qualitätsoptionen, sonst muss ich das Ding irgendwie 2-3 mal neu
starten mit Glück, weil ich es hier kriege.
Ja, Moin Leute, Bozilen ja schon wieder viele Leute am Start, so direkt quasi die Twitch
Abobox Lurker sind schon wieder am Start, Anatomy ist auch wieder am Start, ähm, warst
du gestern dabei?
Gestern gab es auch schon mal zweieinhalb Stunden, habe ich hier Memetool Version 2
rumgebastelt, ähm, heute müssen wir uns leider ein bisschen Javascript Sachen wieder
widmen.
Ja, heute müssen wir uns leider ein bisschen Javascript Sachen widmen, wobei nicht nur.
Moin, xFatal1337, übrigens, nice, wie viele Follows das gegeben hat, ich meine, klar,
die meisten Leute kamen wahrscheinlich vom Video, aber trotzdem ein paar kamen auch über
Twitch, die keine Ahnung hatten, dass ich auf YouTube irgendwas hochgeladen habe.
Javascript, ja, ist tatsächlich ein bisschen, ein bisschen eklig, ich meine, das neue Frontend
ist jetzt Javascript-mäßig noch gar nicht mal so hässlich im Vergleich zu dem alten,
so war das alte Ding auch, man muss sagen, mit Vue sieht das alles relativ hübsch aus,
deswegen bin ich da auch schnell mit warm geworden, ich, wie gesagt, ich war nie großartiger
Fan, bisher was mit Javascript zu machen, wäre ich jetzt auch nicht, aber Vue ist so
viel netter als Vanilla-Javascript, da erträgt man das sogar halbwegs, gut, ein paar Sachen
sind natürlich immer noch ziemlich beknackt, zum Beispiel, dass not a number gleich false
ist in Javascript und solche Dinger, stimmt's, wie war das Command noch mal, ich hab ehrlich
gesagt keine Ahnung, das müsst ihr gegen den Mod wissen, falls ein Mod da ist, oder
ich müsste mal meine Nightbot-Commandos angucken, ich guck mal, versuch mal Ausrufezeichen-Tool
oder sowas, wobei das könnte das Screenshot-Tool für BDO gewesen sein, hm, ach Memboard,
richtig, ja, joa klappt doch, kotz schon tot, nee, wieder erwarten, ja, ja, ja, ja,
kotz schon tot, nee, wieder erwarten, finde ich Black Ops 4 gar nicht so schlecht, ich
meine, es sind schon ein paar nervige Sachen dabei und so dieses normale Team-Destmatch-Gebärsche
und so, das fuckt schon ganz schön ab, wobei es geht, man hat zwischendurch halt immer
wieder irgendwelche Runden, die richtig gut sind, aber zum größten Teil fuckt es ab,
aber ich glaube, Black Ops, wenn sie das ordentlich supporten, das könnte einen auch
ein bisschen bei der Stange halten, du hast dir wegen mir geholt, ich hab gesagt, wartet
es mal ab, ich hab gesagt, wartet es mal ab, so, das Ganze starten, ich zeig euch mal,
was wir machen wollen, ich hab noch keine Ahnung, so wirklich, wie wir das am besten
machen, äh, warum startet das nicht, ah, weil der Port nicht stimmt, dann machen wir
den Portcams weg, wir haben das alte Meme-Tool eh nicht mehr an, äh, Moment, wenn ich das
jetzt starte, stimmt, aber die Ports hier wieder nicht, Moment, ich muss mal kurz überlegen,
Ports, Ports, 5000, ähm, die Hotkey-Geschichte, machen wir weg, was ist das für Musik, ETF,
es hört sich an wie ein SNES, Overworld Map-Soundtrack, ist die Musik von der Lautstärke ok, so, muss
ich das noch an irgendeiner Stelle umstellen, ich glaub nicht, ach ja, das war ja im Firefox
verbuggt die Geschichte, wie kann man dem Ding eigentlich sagen, in welchem Browser
er das öffnen soll, ah, Webbrowser, hier kann man es ändern, ok, das ist nice, also
ich muss echt sagen, man kann, über Micro, fühlt sich etwas laut, ja, ich mach mal, ticken
leiser, ich find's immer geil diese Mini-Slider, die dann entweder nur zu laut oder zu leise
zulassen, ja, ich glaub so ist besser, als Standard-Browser festlegen, nein, im Chrome
geht's nämlich lustigerweise, die Firefox Bugs gucken uns halt irgendwann mal an, aber
ich mein Firefox, was brauchst du denn Firefox, ist ja nur mal Main-Browser, warum soll das
da drin nicht funktionieren, ja, der Tommy hat das ja noch gar nicht gesehen, den muss
ich das jetzt natürlich auch mal zeigen, wir haben jetzt hier natürlich neues, warte mal,
neues App-Frontend mit Datenbank im Hintergrund, also sprich, man kann jetzt so ein Bildchen
hier nehmen, reinziehen und da geht so ein Upload-Dialog auf und das hier unten werden
wir heute machen, aktuell ist das eine ganz normale Input-Box und ich will, dass man den
Hotkey quasi hier drin festlegen kann, das heißt, man könnte jetzt die Billig-Variante
machen, dass der User quasi sowas reinschreiben müsste wie, nein, das nicht, wie Ctrl plus
B, aber viel cooler wäre das doch, wenn dieses Input fällt, quasi die Keystrokes captured,
im Moment hier wäre zufällig eine gescheite mechanische Tastatur, die vielleicht ein bisschen
dezenter aussieht, wie das von Logi, ja, ja, kannst du dir was empfehlen?
Nice Azure database, nein, wo denkst du hin, lokale SQLite, Azure database, lokales SQLite,
ja, ähm, kann man das jetzt öffnen?
Ich zeig dir gleich, ich zeig gleich die Tastatur. Ich hab da nämlich ne richtig gute, finde ich.
Also, auf der Arbeit. Ich hab mir zwei gekauft, ich hab mir ne Corsair Gaming-Geschichte für daheim geholt.
Ich hab mir noch ne andere für die Arbeit geholt.
Also ganz normale SQLite-Daten. Mehr brauchst du ja auch nicht.
Genau, da kann man Upload drücken, man kann hier für die Suche, kann man Text eingeben.
Für den Text kann man noch Text-to-Speech anmachen, sich ne Stimme auswählen.
Das müssen wir noch implementieren, das geht noch nicht.
Und dann ein Hotkey festlegen, favorisieren kann man das Ganze, wenn man sagt, man Upload gut ist.
Man kann es dann hier drüber auch wieder löschen.
Und heute wollte ich halt dieses Hotkey-Mechanismus bauen, weil es ist so, das ist auch überschaubart.
Das sollte, glaube ich, heute in ein paar Stunden funktionieren.
Obwohl ich keine Ahnung hab, wie man sowas in JavaScript macht, aber kriegen wir schon hin.
Also ich hätte gern, dass der halt quasi so die Keystrokes captured.
Also sprich, dass ich dann sage, hier drinnen, CTRL B.
Und dass er dann halt quasi für mich reinschreibt, CTRL B.
Dass er dann alles in der Form richtig zum Server schickt und dann halt das richtig macht.
Ich kann jetzt keinen wirklich zumuten, hier drinnen CTRL B reinzuschreiben, weil dann ist bitte die Sache,
die ersten Leute schreiben CTRL, die nächsten Leute Steuerung, die nächsten schreiben GRILL.
Also das ist blöd, das muss automatisch gecaptured werden.
Ja, so ist das.
So, Tastatur.
Ich hab grad gesehen, es gibt noch ein paar Fragen im Chat.
Guck ich mir gleich an.
Tastatur.
Ja, gibt's ein paar sehr schicke.
So, wir haben ja alle Browser.
Wo kommen wir noch an Edge auf?
Ich wollt grad hier, ich hab leider kein Meme-Overlay gerade.
Ich wollt grad hier Wood-Facing.
Edge, so haben wir.
Moving is easy.
Da, geh weg.
Nee, nee, das muss nicht sein.
Wir haben jetzt zumindest mal die wichtigsten Browser auf.
Wir haben ein Chromium auf, ein Chrome und ein Firefox.
Tastatur.
Wer war das nochmal mit Tastatur?
Ah, der Travel.
Also, einmal hier zu Hause, aber wie gesagt, die ist nicht dezent.
Ich zeig dir einfach mal alle beide.
No sellout, ich krieg kein Geld.
Corsair.
Ich glaub, das ist sogar der K95 RGB Platinum.
Das ist das Ding, was ich daheim hab.
Das ist halt komplett oversized, overengineertes Gaming-Crap eigentlich.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was der ausschlaggebende Grund war, warum ich mir die geholt hab für daheim.
Egal, aber sowas willst du eh nicht.
So, und zwar auf der Arbeit hab ich folgende, und die find ich richtig geil.
Hätte ich mir die Corsair-Tastatur nicht gekauft, hätte ich mir die Tastatur einfach doppelt geholt.
Die ich auf der Arbeit, die ich mir für die Arbeit geholt hab.
Ich weiß, das ist eine Ducky-One-Skyline.
Wie hieß das Ding?
Ducky-One-Two-Skyline.
Ja, die hier, genau die hier.
Die gibt's mit ein bisschen unterschiedlichen, bunten Knöpfen.
Es sind ein paar Ersatzknöpfe dabei.
Also man kann da WASD, kann man dann irgendwie noch rausschmachen und so.
Wer macht's braucht?
Man kann sich auch zusätzliche Keys und so noch bestellen.
Aber die ist richtig gut.
Das ist ein richtiger Klotz.
Also das Ding ist, wenn ich so mal hochhebe, ja, also dieses Corsair-Ding.
Wie spricht man die eigentlich aus?
Corsair? Corsair? Corsair?
Wir fragen Google, Google weiß fast alles.
Corsair wahrscheinlich.
Corsair.
Okay, ich bin jetzt auch nicht schlauer.
Wo ist eigentlich unsere?
Wo ist eigentlich unsere Text-to-Speech von gestern?
Monka ist.
Ich kann mich immer über diese Text-to-Speech-Sache immer noch kaputtlachen.
Das müssen wir auch noch einbauen.
Dafür haben wir hier schon die Weep-Stimme zur Auswahl.
So, ich wollte jetzt noch was zur Tastatur sagen.
Genau, also das ist ein richtiger Klotz, das Teil.
Im Vergleich hier zur Corsair.
Die Corsair-Tastatur ist halt größer.
Hat viel mehr Schnickschnack dran.
Ich finde, vom Layout finde ich die hier angenehmer.
Man kann sich noch eine Handballen-Ablage dazu bestellen.
Betrieb kann man sich welche nehmen, welche auch immer man will.
Und eine Tastatur, die ist richtig massiv.
Die wiegt ein Ticken mehr sogar als die Corsair-Tastatur, obwohl die viel größer ist.
Und wenn du damit irgendwelche Einbrecher abwehren willst, ist das die optimale Tastatur.
Und auch so zum Schreiben, das ist richtig gut.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was es für Switche hat.
Ich glaube, ich habe die Brown-Switches.
Die gibt es mit verschiedenen, aber das lohnt sich.
Und das hält sich preislich auch halbwegs in Grenzen.
Gucken, was die bei Amazon kostet.
Ich weiß nicht mal, wo ich sie bestellt habe.
Ich glaube, ich habe sie bei Minefactory oder Alternate bestellt.
Ja, die gibt es sogar noch ein Ticken günstiger.
Ich habe hier irgendwie 120 Euro oder so bezahlt.
Das ist zwar nicht mega billig, aber für die Tastatur ist es wirklich gut.
Ich finde, das ist eines der besten mechanischen Tastaturen, die es gibt.
Ich glaube, ich habe sie hier bei Minefactory.
Oh, war geil, ins Hals.
Ich kann jetzt schreiben.
Das ist auch so ein Ding.
Auf dieser Corsair-Tastatur, ich kriege es ums verreckentliche Fehler, blind zu schreiben.
Das klappt einfach nicht.
Die Tasten fühlen sich so kleiner, obwohl sie irgendwie nicht klein sind.
Aber das geht ordentlich tippen, geht auf der hier viel besser, obwohl die gefühlt die Hälfte kostet.
Genau, geht los bei 118 Euro.
So, den Dreh habe ich auch bezahlt.
Also, das Ding kann man echt empfehlen.
Ein Lehrer in meiner Schule sagt, dass das SDRG auf der Tastatur für Strings steht.
Na gut, was Lehrer so sagen.
Das ist auch viel besser, wenn der Tag ein ist.
Nicht mal der echte Cherry.
Der Cherry hat nichts Gescheites.
Cherry hatte nichts, was mir gefallen hat.
Das war immer nichts Halbes und nichts Ganzes.
Ja, die K95 habe ich auch.
Das ist echt gut, das Ding.
Aber wie gesagt, ich kann auf der...
Das könnte vielleicht auch an den Speed-Switches liegen.
Aber ich kann hier auf der viel, viel, viel besser tippen.
Das merke ich ja auf der Arbeit, als hier auf der Heimat, auf der Corsair-Tastatur.
Dafür spielt es sich angenehmer mit und so soll es ja im Prinzip auch sein.
Eats.
Das ist Geschmackssache mit den Tastaturen.
Also wenn ich...
Also ich muss ja sagen, ich quäle ja die Leute auf der Arbeit schon ein bisschen.
Weil ich meine, wenn man mal richtig reinhaut in so eine mechanische...
Und die hier, die Corsair, ist noch leise im Vergleich zu der Ducky 12.
Die macht eher so...
So hört sich das Ding ungefähr standardmäßig auf der Arbeit an.
Ich habe schon ein paar Gummiregeln drunter, dass sie leiser ist.
Das geht den Leuten schon ein bisschen auf den Keks.
Aber das Schreibgefühl finde ich richtig gut.
Numpad. Jaja, Numpad.
Numpad, braucht man.
Ohne Numpad ist kacke.
Habe ich die ohne Numpad gezeigt gerade?
Ne, mit...
Oh, ich habe die ohne Numpad.
Ich brauche die mit...
Mit Numpad.
Natürlich mit Numpad.
Da kann man auch, wenn man krasser CS-GoPro ist, der mit Numpad spielt,
da wird man dann auch glücklich damit.
Hauen wir mal weiter.
So, ich habe schon irgendwelche Links geschickt bekommen.
Get modifier state, sonst was.
Das werde ich mir dann alles angucken, wenn wir dabei sind.
Weil vielleicht geht es auch relativ einfach mit Vue.
Ich weiß es nicht. Gucken wir mal.
Guck mal, der Eax ist auch da. Moin.
Und Eax, hast du noch ein bisschen Black Ops gespielt?
Ja, mal Leute, wie soll ich ihn in die Schrift machen? So?
So? Oder so?
Ich meine, so sie...
So passt er halt deutlich mehr drauf, ne?
Sag mal, wie kann ich denn das jetzt hier wieder einklappen?
Mittel? So?
Okay.
Ah.
Also, ähm, ich denke mal, wo habe ich denn das jetzt hier auf?
Ah, ich habe es wieder zugemacht. Ganz clever.
Okay. Ja, was jetzt?
Zwei? Zwei? Mittel? Mittel?
Also die meisten wollen so, wie es jetzt ist.
Ich lasse erst mal. Falls es irgendwie...
Vielleicht muss ich es kleiner stellen, wenn ich zu wenig sehe.
Ich meine, das ist ja übersichtlich.
Das sind halt 100 Zeilen HTML. Da gibt es Schlimmeres.
Ähm...
Also, dann gucken wir uns jetzt mal an.
Wie könnte man das am sinnvollsten machen?
Also wir wollen hier...
Control. Wir wollen hier...
Keystrokes capturen.
Und dann wollen wir das möglichst einfach zum Server senden.
Am besten so alles im gleichen Format, dass man möglichst wenig konvertieren muss.
Wir senden das als Form.
Das heißt, irgendwelche Jason-Spielereien fallen an der Stelle raus.
Oder ich muss Jason in der Form verpacken.
Und dann quasi auf dem Server wieder parsen, was irgendwie...
Blödsinnig ist.
Achso. Wird es irgendwann auch möglich sein, Memes aus einer Datenbank zuzugreifen?
So eine Art Verzeichnis, worauf...
Meinst du jetzt lokal, bei dir oder global?
Ich habe mir überlegt, ob ich sowas global einbauen soll.
Allerdings natürlich keine Memedb oder so.
Von mir, weil ich meine Copyright und sowas.
Ich habe mir überlegt, ob ich nicht quasi eine bisschen schnellere Suche für sowas hier einbaue.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die eine API haben.
Irgendwie sowas.
Also ich weiß nicht, wenn es irgendwie so eine gescheite Seite mit ordentlicher API gibt,
da könnte man sich überlegen, ob man nicht so eine kleine Suche hier einbaut, dass man es direkt adden kann.
Ich werde das nicht hausen, aber wenn es einen Service gibt,
der eine ganz gute Datenbank hat und eine ordentliche API für,
dann ist es jetzt cool, dass man nicht mal API sagt, sondern A-P-I.
Oder A-P-I.
Die Leute sagen nicht mehr API.
Die sagen Max, das heißt A-P-I.
Oder A-P-I.
Nein, das heißt nicht mehr...
A-P-I ist outdated.
Das sagt man nicht mehr.
Leute, ihr könnt mich nicht debaten mit irgendwelchen komischen Links.
Ich habe einen Addon, was mir eine Vorschau von dem Link anzeigt.
Das heißt, da ist nichts mit Debate.
Debate-resistent.
Out-debated.
So.
Das sind die Java-Leute, genau.
Twitch-Emotes sind ein bisschen problematisch,
weil die Twitch-Emotes zu klein sind.
Wir brauchen etwas Kurseres und eine ordentliche Auflösung.
Also, brauchen wir nicht.
Letztendlich kann jeder darin adden, was er will.
Wie gesagt, das wird ja ohne Bilder ausgeliefert.
Man sollte halt schon ein bisschen was in einer ordentlichen Auflösung nehmen.
Die Twitch-Emotes sind halt so klein.
Die gibt es maximal in vierfacher Größe.
Manche sind tatsächlich ganz brauchbar groß mittlerweile.
Aber man müsste das ja quasi so vergrößern, dass es passt und das sieht halt scheiße aus.
Nehmen wir mal irgendwas anderes.
Nehmen wir mal hier Anäle.
Ich warte jetzt noch, bis einer mit irgendwelchen Bomb-Geschichten kommt.
Das sieht halt zu schlecht aufgelöst aus.
Ich brauche irgendwelche ordentlichen Bildchen.
Dazu fällt mir bloß ein.
Dann fangen wir mal an.
Also, ich denke mal, dass wir...
Also, einen Input-Feld für den Hotkey haben wir schon.
Wenn wir darin jetzt Keystrokes captchern wollen, müssen wir erstmal irgendeinen On-Keypress machen.
Ich gehe mal stark voraus, dass es einfach Keypress heißt.
Es wird wahrscheinlich On-Keypress heißen.
Genau, Keypress, Keydown, Keyup.
Wir können auch Keydown nehmen.
Aber es ist eigentlich egal.
Wir nehmen mal Keypress.
Ja, Tobi, wenn du das hinkriegst, da kannst du verdammt viel...
Also, es ist wahrscheinlich mathematisch gar nicht möglich, sowas ordentlich zu machen.
Aber wenn du das schaffst, da kannst du wahrscheinlich Millionen schaffen.
So.
Okay, On-Keypress ist... heißt das?
Also ist es Add Keypress in View.
So, und dann brauchen wir unsere Funktion.
Wie nennt man das denn?
Capture Key oder irgendwie sowas.
Gut.
Und ich habe heute was gelesen.
In irgendwie seit Vue.js Version 2 noch, hast du nicht gesehen, gibt es jetzt ein neues Feature.
Das probieren wir jetzt hier mal aus.
Und zwar kann ich sagen, Punkt Prevent.
Das heißt, das geht immer noch hier in meinen Capture Key Funktion rein, wenn einer Keypress.
Allerdings, die Standard Sachen, die passen...
Oh, ich bin da übrigens voll falsch, ne?
Warum sagt mir keiner, dass ich komplett im falschen Element bin?
Ich muss doch gar nicht hin.
Ich muss hier zum...
Hier.
Nicht Text to Speech.
Hotkey, da muss ich rein.
What the fuck?
So.
Allerdings Standard Event wird nicht ausgeführt.
Das heißt, in der Input Box erscheint nichts.
Gucken wir mal.
Eine Sache machen wir noch.
Wir stellen an, dass standardmäßig die Form angezeigt wird.
Die sieht zwar hässlich aus, aber das macht nichts.
Sieht ein bisschen kaputt aus, aber egal.
Okay, das funktioniert schon mal nicht mehr.
Das ist gut.
So ist das gewollt.
Jetzt wird er natürlich irgendwelche untersuchen.
Krass.
Das ist auf Deutsch.
Warum ist das auf Deutsch?
Ich hab das...
Systemsprache Englisch.
Untersuchen.
Okay, untersuchen wir das mal.
Und stellen natürlich fest, dass die Events nicht gibt.
Gut, dann werden wir das mal einfügen.
Capture Key.
So.
Ja, man.
Console Lock.
Gucken, ob das überhaupt funktioniert.
So prinzipiell, wie ich mir das gedacht hab.
Was?
Okay, das funktioniert.
Moment, was hat der hier für Schmerzen?
Ich hab irgendwo einen Tippfehler drinne.
Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, wo...
Wie find ich das jetzt gescheit?
Ich mein, das ist nicht schlimm.
Das geht trotzdem, aber...
On Element.
Ja, ich hab irgendwo einen Komma eingefügt, aber...
Wo ist das denn?
Daneben bringt mir ja nix.
Weil, das ist der View Source Code.
Das ist...
What the fuck?
Find ich das jetzt gescheit?
Was ist das denn?
Wer braucht einen Debugger, wenn es die Konsole gibt?
Das ist komplett overrated.
Ich find vor allem Java-Skripten so dynamisches Zeug.
Find ich, ist praktisch immer so ganz billiges See-out.
Debugge.
Was ist die Mission?
Die Mission ist, hier die Keys zu grabben.
Dass man quasi nicht mehr selbst tippen muss.
Control plus B, sondern drücken kann.
Control und B.
Und dann kann ich das zum Server schicken.
Also, ich zeig dir das mal.
Geh fort.
Wie jetzt gemacht.
So, what?
Ich muss mal kurz ein bisschen Ando-Action machen.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich gerade kaputt gemacht hab.
Irgendwas hier, oder?
Wartet mal.
Ach, da!
Alter.
Oder nicht?
Da!
Oh, Mann.
Das ist nicht mehr kacke zu finden.
Die Mission ist, dass man vorm Upload den Hotkey angeben kann.
Mit dem man das Bildchen dann quasi overlayen möchte.
Also sprich, du sagst dann hier Control B als Hotkey.
Und wenn du dann Control B drückst, zeigt der dir Overlay Omega 0 an.
Also, wenn man das abgelaudet hat.
Und aktuell war es so, man musste hier unten jetzt quasi rein schreiben.
Control plus B.
Upload.
Und dann hat es auch nicht funktioniert.
Und jetzt will ich das Ganze Captchern.
Also sprich, dass man drückt Control B und dann...
Control B.
Ja.
Warum schreibt der da jetzt was rein?
Ach so, weil ich das gelöscht hab, ne?
Ja.
Das ist die Idee.
Genau.
Okay, das Captchern.
Das funktioniert.
Schau mal, wie man sieht.
Aber...
Control und Alt Captchert endlich.
Ich vermute mal, weil das irgendwelche Modifier-Keys sind.
Da machen wir nicht Key Press, sondern machen Key Down.
Da müsste ja alles dabei sein dann.
Fragt mich nicht, warum, weil JavaScript-Logik.
Guckt, jetzt ist auch Control mit dabei.
Okay, lassen wir uns das mal ausgeben, was wir für einen Knopf drücken.
Event und dann haben wir Event...
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Event, wie heißt das?
Character?
Weiß nicht.
Gucken wir mal.
Aha.
Key heißt das Ganze einfach.
Da hätte ich auch drauf kommen können.
Also es ist einfach nur Key heißt.
Guckt, jetzt kriegt man bei Shift-A, kriegen wir zwei Events.
Einmal für Shift und einmal für A.
So muss das sein.
So, wir haben Character-Code...
Character...
Null?
Key-Code.
Moment, warum ist Character-Code und Key-Code unterschiedlich?
Null sollte es ja als Character gar nicht geben.
Key-Code 65, das ist ein A.
Ein kleines A eigentlich.
Ja, das passt doch eigentlich ganz gut.
Okay, so kriegt man die ganzen Campel schon mal gecaptured.
Das ist doch schön.
Es ist JavaScript-Logik.
Ich verstehe nicht, warum man Key-Down verwenden muss und nicht Key-Press.
Aber JavaScript, ich sag da einfach nichts.
Wir machen jetzt einfach weiter.
Was ist denn für dich die beste Private-Cloud-Lösung?
Next-Cloud.
Wenn man viele Features braucht, Next-Cloud.
Ansonsten, wenn man nicht viele Features braucht,
wenn man einfach nur File-Sync will, finde ich ist...
das hier am besten.
Wenn man einfach nur File-Sync haben will,
ohne großartige Sperenzien, dann nimmt man das.
Und wenn man das ganze Paket aus Caldav, Carddav, Journals, To-Do's,
Kalender, File-Sync und alles gedürnt haben will,
dann kann man Next-Cloud nehmen.
Plus die ganzen Add-ons und so, die es gibt.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich in JavaScript cool.
Obwohl es wahrscheinlich weniger JavaScript ist,
sondern eher Browser-Geschichte.
Aber das finde ich auch cool, dass man in JavaScript
quasi alles mögliche Konsole loggen kann,
und das nicht nur Text ist, sondern wirklich Objekt,
wo man durchklicken kann.
Ich meine, das ist wirklich cool.
Das nimmt man ja quasi schon als gegeben hin,
wenn man im Browser was macht, aber...
Ich meine, das hast du halt bei normalen Terminal-Output nicht.
Du gibst Objekt aus und hast die ganze Geschichte.
Das ist so typisch Dubstep-Musik.
Immer wieder die gleichen drei Töne
und im Hintergrund...
Du kannst coden, ja.
Wobei ich das Wort programmieren besser finde.
Weiß ich, coden, das hat man früher auch immer gerne gesagt.
Ich finde, das wirkt irgendwie so...
Du tippst halt irgendwie Quellcode ein ohne Sinn und Verstand.
Okay, also, wir kriegen den Graf schon mal gecaptchert.
Wie machen wir jetzt weiter?
Also, von der Logik her würde ich sagen,
wir brauchen erst einmal in unserem Model
für die Form brauchen wir irgendwie
mal ein bisschen mehr als Hotkey, weil...
Okay, wir machen es mal als String.
Erstmal einfach nur als String, um zu gucken,
ob das funktioniert.
Capture-Key, okay, dann sagen wir jetzt...
Das, jetzt kommt jetzt wieder
ewige Schlange aus Aufrufdingern,
weil JavaScript, also sagen wir mal Dings,
Popup, Form, Hotkey, gleich, Event.
Wir probieren das mal aus,
ob es prinzipiell funktioniert.
Event und dann einfach nur Key.
Ja, das funktioniert.
Guck, der captchaht.
Und Shift und so captchaht er auch.
Das finde ich ganz cool.
Alt-Captchahter, Ctrl-Captchahter,
Shift-Captchahter, ähm...
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass das GR für Graf steht,
aber gut.
Captchahter, Windows-Taste-Captchahter.
Er captchaht alles, also, das ist gut.
So, jetzt müssen wir natürlich noch gucken,
wie man das...
Was läuft dahinter Vue?
Also, es läuft frontendmäßig Vue.js
und backend ist ASP.NET Core.
Es ist aber auch hauptsächlich Vue.js geworden,
weil...
Also, ich bin nicht der große JavaScript-Hacksore
und Kenner,
und nachdem mir Vanilla JavaScript immer so
unglaublich auf den Kicks geht,
habe ich mal geguckt, was zurzeit frontend
technisch so angesagt ist,
weil in JavaScript ist es ja so,
dass was vor ein paar Jahren frontend
technisch angesagt war,
ist ja heute komplett outdated,
aber komplett...
Also, wer sich vor drei Jahren mit JavaScript,
mit dem JavaScript-Ökosystem beschäftigt hat,
der ist heute komplett outdated,
so quasi wie vor 30 Jahren bei anderen Sachen.
Das heißt, ich habe jetzt mal geguckt,
was angesagt ist,
und zurzeit ist Vue.js total angesagt,
und ich muss sagen, ich finde das echt gut.
Das macht wirklich...
Das macht Spaß.
Das hätte ich nicht gedacht,
dass ich das bei JavaScript sage, ja,
Vue.js macht Spaß.
Wird hier auch auf meinem Stream,
die Rechner möchten sich gerade
Visual Studio aktualisieren.
Nein.
Ich brauche den Download gerade.
Also, das macht tatsächlich Spaß,
und es ist für JavaScript-Verhältnisse
ziemlich intuitive,
die ganze Vue-Geschichte.
Ich meine, guck mal, wie simpel das jetzt war.
Du machst hier im Endeffekt einfach an...
Du machst einfach an diesem Input,
sagst dir hier,
Keydown, Prevent, also sprich Standard-Event,
wenn es nicht ausführt,
gibst du eine Funktion ein,
schreibst die Funktion hin,
und es funktioniert einfach.
Das ist eats-as-fuck, ja.
Ja, no-skiller, das geht bestimmt noch schöner.
Ich muss mir da mal Gedanken machen.
Okay.
Also, das Captchern von Sachen
funktioniert schon mal ziemlich gut.
Wir werden das wahrscheinlich trennen müssen.
Wir werden das einmal trennen müssen,
wie es intern gespeichert wird
und wie es in diesem Input angezeigt wird,
weil ich will ja eigentlich die Keycodes.
Ich will die Keycodes haben,
also ich will hier nicht...
Ich will eigentlich zum Server nicht übertragen,
dass ich jetzt gerade A gedrückt habe,
sondern ich möchte zum Server übertragen,
ich will Keycode 65,
Modifier-Keycode, keine Ahnung, 17 oder so.
Ich glaube, 17 ist das Windows-Taste oder Schrift oder so.
Und das will ich eigentlich übertragen,
weil dann ist es nämlich viel einfacher wieder
auf dem, wie gesagt,
ich labe jetzt einfach nur mal für mich zum Nachdenken,
weil dann ist es im Backend viel einfacher für mich,
das quasi letztendlich wieder in
Windows Desktop Keycodes umzuwandeln,
anstatt wenn ich jetzt hier irgendwelche JavaScript
String-Representations von diesen Keycodes nehme.
Also ich will eigentlich hier intern speichern,
den Keycode, allerdings anzeigen,
anzeigen will ich Shift und so.
Das heißt, wir brauchen das schon mal,
wir brauchen schon mal zwei Sachen.
Also wir brauchen schon mal einen
einen Store für
eigentlich die eigentliche Hotkey-Geschichte
und die Keycodes.
Kenne keine moderne Anwendung,
welche noch auf PHP aufbaut.
Doch, da gibt es relativ viele.
Zunächst Cloud zum Beispiel,
was ich gerade von hatten.
Sind die Keycodes standardisiert,
allzu programmiersprachend, unabhängig?
Ich würde mal sagen, die meisten.
Also von A bis Z dürfte einfach
normaler ASCII-Code sein.
Control und so ist auch irgendwie,
ich glaube, ich bin mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher,
ich glaube Shift, Steuerung, Alt,
das ist irgendwie 15, 16, 17 oder 16, 17, 18
oder sowas in der Richtung.
Also Chick ein Chasen.
Ja, das ist, das war das eigentliche Ziel,
allerdings haben wir eine Form.
Das heißt, ich muss erst mal gucken,
wie ich das Capture...
Okay, das Capture ist einfach an sich,
das funktioniert so.
Wir brauchen jetzt zwei Sachen.
Wir brauchen einfach, wie man das anzeigt
und...
Kann man noch was hier machen?
Kann das hier auch was gehabt?
Ha! Nice.
Okay, prinzipiell kann es das.
Das werden wir nicht so lassen.
Das...
Okay.
Okay, das erste ist, wir müssen stoppen,
wenn...
Also, wir brauchen, also,
wenn man Escape drückt,
wir müssen mal überlegen,
wie sich das Ding verhalten soll.
Wenn man Escape drückt, dann Clear.
Das machen wir als erstes.
If event keycode gleich, ja,
was zum Teufel ist Escape?
27, 7...
13?
27, okay.
27, dann wollen wir,
wir alias uns...
Übrigens, kann mir das mal
irgendjemand erklären?
Ich weiß ja, ich habe gerade gesehen,
im Chat sind ein paar JavaScript-
Spezialisten am Start.
Als App wäre es noch cooler.
Du kannst doch einfach die Webseite
auf dem Smartphone aufmachen.
Da brauchen wir keine extra App für.
Was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Genau.
Also, ich habe jetzt gesehen,
dass ganz viele JavaScript-Pros,
die stehen auf const.
Die nehmen keinen var mehr,
die nehmen const.
Also, JavaScript hat hier irgendwie
mindestens drei verschiedene Sachen
so variablen irgendwie anlegen.
Was ist denn eigentlich
der Unterschied dazwischen?
Also, ich meine jetzt rein hier
an der Stelle im Code
macht es ja überhaupt keinen Unterschied,
ob ich irgendwie sage,
let hotkey gleich das da.
Das ist irgendwie eine Scoping-Geschichte
wahrscheinlich.
Aber wie?
Das macht eigentlich überhaupt
keinen Unterschied an der Stelle jetzt.
Ich meine, ich nehme var,
weil ich das von C Sharp gewöhnt bin.
Was ist der Unterschied
zwischen den drei Dingern?
War nicht mehr.
Let ist nur innerhalb des Blocks,
wo es definiert war, gültig.
Das bedeutet, hier drin könnte ich...
Also, wir lernen JavaScript.
Das heißt, hier drin könnte ich jetzt
das hotkey nicht verwenden, oder was?
Wenn es nur im Block gültig ist.
Const ist konstant.
Ja, gut, da werde ich auch drauf kommen.
Okay, das heißt, const bedeutet,
ich könnte jetzt sowas hier nicht machen.
Das wird da nicht gehen, ne?
Weil const...
Also sprich, wenn ich
in der ganzen Funktion verwenden will,
dann nehme ich var.
Weil let geht im Block nicht.
Const kann ich nicht ändern.
Also var, warum nicht var?
Ich meine, wenn ich eine Variante habe,
die ich ändern will, ja?
Also mal angenommen, ich habe jetzt hier sowas wie...
return value gleich false.
Und ich habe jetzt hier ganz, ganz viele ifs.
Und da setze ich halt return value
dann entweder auf true
oder lasse es auf false oder sonst was.
Und am Ende sage ich halt return.
Dann muss ich es doch var machen, oder?
Weil nur mit var kann ich es ändern.
Oder geht es mit let dann auch?
Also geht mit let, das ist ein Untergrund.
Probieren wir jetzt einfach mal aus.
Let.
Okay.
Sollen wir jetzt escape drücken?
Geht doch.
Ja, dann können wir auch let nehmen.
Oder wir nehmen var, weil ich var einfach erschreiten kann.
Alles rauf.
Ich meine, alle vars zu const...
Ja, okay.
Aber in dem Fall, das geht jetzt aber...
Das sollte jetzt aber nicht gehen, oder?
Ups.
Ah, ja, okay, okay.
Verstehe.
Das heißt, mit const kann man sich dann logischerweise darauf verlassen,
dass es ein Fehler wird, wenn man es versucht zu ändern.
Best practice.
Wir sind ja bestest practice hier.
Sind wir ja schon bekannt für.
Vor allem auch für unsere tollen serverseitigen Checks,
was abgelaudet wird.
Die sind ja auch ganz große, ganz hohe Kunst.
Aktuell kann jeder uploaden, was er will.
Warte, let hallo1...
Ach so.
Jetzt ernsthaft?
Ist das wirklich so?
Okay, an der Stelle müsste es true sein.
An der Stelle müsste es dann wieder false sein, oder wie?
Das wird ja immer wirrer.
Nö.
Was auch immer.
Wir machen erst mal weiter, sonst wird das nichts.
Okay.
Also das erste, was wir machen müssen, ist, wenn man escape drückt,
dann ist es relativ easy, wenn es doch mal war, als wir irgendwie...
Ja, das ist scheiße.
Ich kann ja selber noch ändern später.
Hier, wir aliassen uns das mal, dass wir nicht jedes Mal
den ganzen Mist schreiben müssen.
Form, hotkey.
Geht das so?
Nee, das wird wahrscheinlich gar nicht gehen.
Also das brauche ich dann schon noch mal.
So.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt escape da drinnen drücke, ist es weg.
Wobei ich noch returnen müsste danach, weil sonst es escape
noch mal reingeschrieben wird.
Aber das funktioniert prinzipiell.
How do you understand all this?
Don't understand it.
It's JavaScript.
I'm a big JavaScript noob.
So.
Jetzt haben wir das Ganze schon mal gelöscht.
Das heißt, wir gehen dann an der Stelle raus, weil es escape ist.
Okay.
Also prinzipiell kann ich jetzt schon mal sowas hier sagen.
Das ist noch eigentlich schon mal gar nicht schlecht.
So ich sage jetzt ctrl a.
Wir resetten, das ist schon mal nicht schlecht.
Wir machen das mal anders.
Ich habe eine Idee.
Wir machen das hotkey weg.
Dann brauche ich aber zwei verschiedene.
Timescript habe ich schon mal was mitgemacht.
Timescript ist wirklich nice.
Warum ich jetzt hier nicht mit Timescript mache, ist, weil ich das ja
auch, wie gesagt, es kommt ja dann alles auf GitHub und ich will, dass die
Leute möglichst einfach mitmachen können.
Und Timescript erhöht die Hürde halt noch mal, weil du brauchst halt, wenn
nicht Gradvisial Studio hast und selbst da auch viele Sachen nicht
funktionieren, brauchst du für Timescript halt
erst mal musst du npm Zeug installieren, dann musst du dann
Timescript Compiler anwerfen und sowas.
Das macht es für mich zu kompliziert, für einfach forken und
ein bisschen mitbusteln.
Okay, ich muss jetzt mal kurz in mich gehen.
Wie machen wir das jetzt am besten?
Also in irgendeinem String einfach speichern, dann können wir das
Ganze schon mal nicht.
Das ist kacke.
Das funktioniert richtig.
Und wir wollen ja auch später vom Server einen...
Wo ist denn das Solution Explorer?
Wir wollen ja auch später vom Server hier uns den Hotkey drinne
speichern.
Kurz ausmachen.
Also wir wollen ja dann eigentlich auch sagen String Hotkey.
Das brauchen wir ja.
Das ist quasi das, was dann auch in die Datenbank geschrieben wird, was das
jeweilige Bildchen für einen Hotkey hat.
So, das heißt wir machen jetzt mal hier eine neue Klasse für diese Hotkeys.
Das nennen wir eben Hotkey.
In ID.
So.
Und was, was müssen wir für so einen Hotkey in der Datenbank speichern?
Also wir müssen einmal natürlich ein...
Was ist das?
Also wir müssen in der Datenbank auf jeden Fall mal den Keycode speichern.
Den brauchen wir später, um das eigentliche Keymapping zu machen.
Dann müssen wir die Modifier speichern.
Haben wir Twitch Prime geholt? Wollt ihr gerne mal eins abschenken?
Das ist sehr nett von dir.
Realer Joke.
Oder habe ich jetzt...
The Real A-Joke.
Aber ich habe keinen...
Ich habe kein Affiliate und kein Twitch Partnerschaft.
Ich habe es auch bis jetzt, ich erzähle es dir seit einem halben Jahr schon,
dass ich mal mich darum kümmern werde, so, weil das immer viele Leute fragen.
Ich habe es immer durchgemacht.
Okay.
Dann müssen wir uns speichern, ob...
Okay, dann speichern wir uns, ob Control gedrückt wird.
Dann speichern wir uns, ob Alt gedrückt wurde.
Dann speichern wir uns, ob...
Weil es könnte ja auch sein, dass wir sowas haben, wie...
Also es könnte ja sein, dass jemand sagt,
ich möchte als Hotkey nicht nur Control B,
sondern Control Alt und B oder sowas.
Also gucken wir mal, was wir für Modifier unterstützen.
Normalerweise würde ich das so machen.
Aber ich sage euch auch gleich, warum das nicht geht.
Normalerweise würde ich dann hier sowas machen, keine Ahnung.
Also einfach hier stellvertretend sowas hier.
Also nicht Object, da würde ich irgendwas anderes für nehmen.
Und dann Keys.
So, da hast du hier irgendeinen Array mit...
Mit deinen Keys drin, ja.
Das wäre eigentlich die einfachste Geschichte.
Also wahrgenommen, wir hätten jetzt hier irgendwie eine, ja,
ein Key, Keyobjekt.
Dann könnte man sogar ein Characterobjekt oder irgendwie sowas machen, so.
Und das wäre jetzt quasi, das wäre jetzt quasi mein Hotkey.
Und der Hotkey setzt sich dann eben zusammen aus beliebig vielen Modifiern.
Modifier sind halt Alt, Control und Shift plus ein Key.
Das würde ich normalerweise so machen.
Die Sache ist die an der Stelle.
Warum ich es nicht so machen kann, ist...
Man kann Arrays nicht in der Datenbank speichern.
Und wir müssen den Hotkey ja speichern.
Das heißt, ich müsste entweder einen, ja,
irgendeinen JSON-Ding da drin speichern als String.
Und dann quasi immer wieder konvertieren.
Oder wir machen das anders.
Oder wir machen halt ein extra Hotkey-Objekt.
Weil das kann ich in der Datenbank speichern.
Also sprich, jedes Meme-Objekt hat ein Meme-Hotkey-Objekt.
Und genau für sowas ist eine Datenbank da, das zu speichern.
So, Control, Alt, Windows.
Und was brauchen wir noch?
Shift.
Übrigens, falls ich irgendwas übersehe,
schreibt es hier mit add-woblaws.
Äh, ja, bool.
Ist doch richtig.
Sag mal, hat, hat, ähm...
Hat Ritual Studio sowas wie Block Select oder so?
Select Colors of Text, ja, genau.
Shift, Alt.
Aha.
Krass.
Nice-u.
Ah, hab wieder was gelernt.
Ich hab's schon vergessen. Was war's?
Shift, Alt.
Shift, Alt. Oh, nice.
Uh.
Hoho.
Krass. So, Keycode.
Und man konnte doch irgendwie auch Zeilen verschieben.
Wie ging das hier auch noch mal?
Wie konnte man Zeilen verschieben?
Shift, Alt, Up. Shift, Alt, Down.
Äh.
Oder auch nicht.
Ach, Alt, einfach nur Alt, okay.
Ja, nice.
Scheiß auf Kommentare.
Offerrated.
Ich wollte gerade alle Netzen Kommentare reinschreiben.
Das ist... Nee, nee, nee.
Damit fangen wir das gar nicht an.
Okay.
So, also, so speichern wir das in der Datenbank.
Das heißt, irgendwie so ungefähr müssen wir das jetzt auch in unserem Frontend abbilden.
Das heißt, Hotkey wird ein eigenes JavaScript-Objekt
mit dem gleichen Shit drinnen,
nämlich Ctrl, False,
Alt,
Win,
False,
Shift,
Keycode,
Null. Mir fällt nämlich gerade Xpresseres ein.
So, und weil Keycode Null,
machen wir hier draus auch einen Nullable-Int.
Wo wir alle C-Sharp-Features verwenden.
Gut. Ähm.
Okay.
Das gefällt mir jetzt schon mal viel besser als vorher.
Und ich glaube, wir brauchen noch ein zweites Feld für die Anzeige.
Aber es ist egal.
Scheiß mal auf die Anzeige im Feld erstmal,
dass wir die Tastendrücke richtig
gespeichert kriegen.
Mittlere Maustaste.
Stimmt, das könnte tatsächlich funktionieren.
Nö.
Mittlere Maustaste macht in Visual Studio einfach mal gar nichts.
Das ist natürlich, äh,
verschenktes Potenzial, ja.
Oh, ich gebe gerade hier große Diskussionen.
TypeScript.
Oder JavaScript.
Ich persönlich finde TypeScript ziemlich gut.
Wo hast du eigentlich deine Server stehen?
Also deine Public Server. Das willst du nicht wissen.
Das ist der reudigste, schlechteste.
Dafür die will ich auch keine Werbung machen.
Hosting-Anbieter aller Zeiten, bei dem ich den Server habe.
Und den habe ich auch nur für
meine, ähm,
so Sachen wie z.B.
Location-Tracking.
Also sprich, ich habe hier meine Heimautomatisierungsgeschichte,
dass ich erkenne, ob ich auf dem
Heimweg bin von der Arbeit und sowas in der Richtung.
Und das ist, aber ich meine, das
ist auch wirklich ein Kack-Anbieter, weil
die kriegen kein Geld richtig.
Also, die können das gar nicht richtig machen.
Die hatten mal ein Angebot,
irgendwie, ich weiß nicht mehr, was es war.
Ich sage jetzt einfach mal 35 Dollar.
35 Dollar Lifetime.
Also sprich, du bezahlst einmal nicht 35 Dollar
und kriegst deine
VM mit Public IPv4-Adresse
Lifetime, haben sie gesagt damals.
Und bis jetzt ist die immer noch da.
Die kackt zwar ab und zu mal ab,
aber sie ist gnadenlos billig.
Billiger als jeder andere Hosting-
anbieter ever.
Wozu sendest du die Key-Inputs
jetzt noch ans Backend?
Ich sende die Key-Inputs nicht
ans Backend. Ich möchte,
nachdem man einen
mit diesen Inputs einen
Hotkey definiert hat,
will ich natürlich dem
Backend mitteilen, wie dieser
Hotkey ist,
weil das Backend muss ja letztendlich das Bild anzeigen.
Dementsprechend muss ich natürlich den
im Frontend definierten Hotkey auch ans Backend
senden, dass der von Windows
das
das Hotkey registrieren kann.
Ich glaube, das wird jetzt ein mega
ekliches JavaScript-Zeug, was ich jetzt von mir gebe.
Also seid schon mal gewarnt.
Also.
Pressed-Key.
Ach komm, wir können auch Event-Punkt-Punkt-Key-Code
nehmen, oder?
Wir nennen es einfach Key.
Event-Punkt-Key-Code.
Ähm.
Ich schreibe es jetzt
einfach mal so,
wie es mir so in den Kopf kommt.
Das ist wahrscheinlich
die absolut ineffizienteste und
hässlichste Lösung,
die es so gibt.
Also als erstes checken wir mal,
ob der Key,
der gedrückt, ich lese jetzt auch mal kurz nicht Chat,
ich muss mal konzentrieren. Der Key, der
gedrückt wurde, gucken wir jetzt erstmal, ob das
Win-Aus-Taste-Alt-Controller-Shift ist.
Also sagen wir so was wie hier
ist Meta oder ist...
Hatten wir gesagt Meta oder Win?
Ich glaube wir hatten gesagt Win, oder?
Win.
Is.
Weil eigentlich heißt das Ding Meta, weil man
fast in jeder Key-Map, wo man
guckt, heißt das Ding
nicht Win-Aus-Taste oder Meta.
So. Event
Keycode.
So ich schreibe das jetzt erstmal so hin, dass es irgendwie
funktioniert und dann überlegen wir uns, wie wir das schön
machen können. Da könnt ihr euch aber auch mal,
ihr könnt euch das ja mal angucken, was ich hier bastle und
wenn ihr dann Verschönerungsvorschläge
habt, schießt los.
Weil das wird wahrscheinlich viel zu lang und viel zu
hässlich. Event Keycode
gleich
...
Ich glaube 16, 17 oder so
ist das immer.
...
18.
Dann haben wir
so was wie Is, Control.
...
Warum ist da nicht Groove Music auf?
Das,
als erstes, wir könnten da bestimmt nicht mit dem Switch draus
machen. Und dann so was
wie Is Modifier Key oder
irgendwie sowas. Das überlegen wir uns gleich, wenn
ich fertig bin.
...
Das war 16, ne?
Ja
K-Code gleich 16
Wie gesagt, ich gucke gerade nicht in den Chat, ich muss mir das mal überlegen
So, jetzt wissen wir, ob der Key, der gerade gedrückt wurde
ob das Win-Aus-Taste Alt-Control oder Shift ist
Okay
Und wir wollen jetzt
Ich muss das noch mal starten
Wir wollen jetzt, ja, das, also das
Mal überlegen, wie sich das Ding verhalten soll
Wir wollen
Stop-If-Escape
Wir wollen Stop-If-Mod-Key-Zweimal
Also sprich, der gleiche, wenn der gleiche Mod-Key zweimal gedrückt wird
wollen wir auch resetten die Form
Wenn
Wenn A bis Z 0 bis 9
zweimal dann auch reset
Weil es könnte ja sein, dass einer so quasi sagt
Ctrl, also Ctrl-A
A, was kein Shortcut mehr ist, was auch keinen Sinn ergibt, wie soll ich das mappen
Das heißt, sobald der zweite Key kommt
kann man das Ding resetten und darf er wieder von vorne anfangen
Ähm
Ich glaube, das dürften die Fälle gewesen sein, ne
Okay
Das heißt, wir müssen jetzt erstmal gucken, ob
Hot, ne, wie heißt es?
Hot-Key
Hot-Key, also okay, einfach so wie die anderen Dinge auch
Also wir gucken jetzt, ob Hot-Key
Windows-Taste schon gesetzt ist
und ob der aktuell gedrückte Knopf
auch Windows-Taste ist
Wenn das der Fall ist
dann resetten wir
wie resetten wir eigentlich in JavaScript so ein Objekt
Hier gibt es da irgendwas
Ich mein, ich würde jetzt die Billig-Variante machen und
Merkt es euch mal, können wir gleich in der Verschönerungsphase
können wir das dann machen
Ctrl, gleich, Hot
Ich würde es jetzt einfach nochmal reinschreiben, ja
Aber wahrscheinlich geht es viel schöner
Ähm
Weil, sobald man merkt, dass man immer
Sachen ganz oft doppelt und dreifach tippt, dann stimmt
meistens irgendwas nicht
Und kann man schöner machen
Shift
So, also das wollen wir resetten, den ganzen Kram
Also sprich, wenn Windows-Key schon mal gedrückt wurde
und Windows-Key nochmal gedrückt wird, dann wollen wir resetten
Ups
So
Oder
Oh, das wird ein krasses If, das sage ich euch gleich schon
Oder Shift
Oder, äh, oder, geh weg
Shift
Alt
Ctrl
Oder ob das so funktioniert, ja
Also
Alt
IsCtrl
Ne, wisst ihr, es fängt schon an
IsChrome
Shift
Ok, wenn das doppelt gedrückt wird, dann
kommt es weg
Shift
Oh
Sonntagsfehler
Irgendwo Sonntagsfehler
Unexpected Talking
Oh
Was ist das?
Das hat Visual Studio da gerade reingewurstet, oder?
Lol
Object Object
Ah
Ja, wir müssen noch als Model setzen
Ne, haben wir schon
Object Object
Ok
Warum ist das Object Object?
Na gut, wahrscheinlich einfach weil JavaScript keine
Ahnung hat, wie man den
Blödsinn von mir hier anzeigen soll
Gehe ich mal von aus
Model Popup Form, ja, das ist
ok
So, wie machen
wir denn weiter?
Also ich würde sagen, jetzt
ich würde gerne mal testen, ob das prinzipiell
funktioniert, was ich hier gemacht habe
Das IF sieht hässlich aus
Ok, das heißt, das hier können wir schon mal da
mit rein machen
Wir wollen resetten, wenn das ist
ohne Escape gedrückt wird
Ich mach doch mal wieder Chat auf
Nicht resetten, wenn ein weiterer kommt,
eher mit den letzten Buchstaben nehmen, der übergeben wurde
Ja, mal gucken
Ich muss mir erstmal einfach gucken,
ob ich Zapps auf die Reihe kriege
Ok, das funktioniert noch
Ok, also wenn ich den Mist
alles gedrückt habe, dann
Dann will ich es resetten, das ist ok
So, else
Wenn
Ne, else if
Ich muss jetzt gucken, wenn es keine Bedingungen ist, wo er das Ganze resetten muss
Will ich gucken, ob
Wir gucken jetzt mal, ob
Ich mach das mal zum Testen
Hier Keycode gleich
65, das ist ein A
Das weiß ich, wie es funktioniert
Hotkey
Ok
Keycode gleich
Das ist jetzt nur mal zum Testen, aber das müssen wir dann auch dynamisch machen
So, und else
So, und im else müssen wir jetzt
die diese Dinger setzen
Ha, wie macht man das jetzt gescheit?
Ich denke
Also mir fällt jetzt nur was ganz ekliges ein
Wir gucken uns gleich an wie man das wieder was schöner machen könnte
Also ich würde sagen wir könnten jetzt sowas machen
Weil wir müssen jetzt ja am Ende vergucken
Ob quasi der Kram nicht gesetzt ist
Und wenn der nicht gesetzt ist
Dann weisen wir ihn zu
Wenn das aktuelle Keypress Event funktioniert
Okay
Gucken ob das funktioniert
Also ich würde jetzt erwarten
CTRL
CTRL gesetzt ist
Nochmal CTRL würde ich erwarten das resettet ist
CTRL drücken und SHIFT drücken
Würde ich warten das CTRL
Ah ne, ah SHIFT Moment
SHIFT habe ich ja noch gar nicht gebastelt
Irgendwie ist auch die Einrückung ein bisschen schepp oder?
Was zum...
Geier macht der da?
Kann man das irgendwie schön formatieren lassen von Visual Studio?
Kann man das formatieren lassen?
Naja anscheinend nicht
Was auch immer
So SHIFT
SHIFT
Okay also
CTRL und SHIFT gedrückt
Jetzt ist beides gesetzt
Und A gedrückt
Jetzt ist CTRL, SHIFT und A gesetzt
Okay das ist von der Logik her so wie ich das haben will
So und jetzt drücke ich nochmal A
Und jetzt ist alles resettet
Fuck
Ah ja das habe ich ja noch gar nicht
Da müssen wir das noch ein bisschen ekliger machen
Das IF
IF
Oddkey Keycode
Ungleich 0
Alter wie das aussieht ey
CTRL, ALT, A
Sollte jetzt alles gesetzt sein
Ja ALT habe ich ja noch gar nicht drin
Okay SHIFT, SHIFT gesetzt, Keycode A
Ich drücke nochmal A
Und es ist resettet
Okay nice
Das ist okay prinzipiell funktioniert
Das sieht halt hässlich wie die Nacht aus aber
Das klappt also haben wir jetzt hier noch ALT
ALT
WIN
Das geht bestimmt besser als WIN
So nice okay
Jetzt sollte das prinzipiell funktionieren was ich mir gedacht habe
Ich habe das so überlegt habe
Was CTRL
Warum gibt es hier nicht sowas wie neu formatieren einfach
Muss doch irgendwie möglich sein sowas hier
Reformat oder so
So
Also prinzipiell ist von der Logik okay
Das sieht scheiße aus ja
Ach das kann damit ja aber es kippt gar nicht
Bei die Eindrückung ist doch eigentlich okay
Nur dass er Taps macht
Taps sind doof aber
Okay so schlecht ist das gar nicht
Ich meine das ist doch eigentlich relativ klar was er macht
So jetzt muss ich mal Chat durchgucken
Hat er in irgendeiner Verbesserungsvorschläge für diesen Krampel von mir
Kompassions in JavaScript bitte immer mit gleichgleichgleich
Wo ist da der Unterschied
Ist das sowas wie gleichgleich checkt den Wert
Gleichgleichgleich checkt Reference oder irgendwie sowas ist das wahrscheinlich
Du zeigst ein Objekt als String an du musst Object to String machen
Hä
Ich weiß dass ich das Objekt anzeige das ist mir schon klar
Warum das hier natürlich als Objekt Objekt drin ist
Ist ein bisschen doof aber gut kann man nichts machen
Kann man das
Gleichgleichgleich Wert gleichgleichgleich gleicher Typ und Wert
Alle JavaScript
Warum kann er mir hier drinnen nicht
Warum zeigt er mir so dummes Objekt Objekt an
Ich meine kann er mir nicht einfach
Zeigt er denn hier das richtig an wenn ich so mache
Kann er mir nicht hier drinnen mal anzeigen
Wie das Objekt in drinnen aussieht dass ich das nicht immer loggen muss
Ja noch mal was Jason Stringify dein Objekt
Das klappt leider nicht so richtig weil ich verwende das gleiche Modell ja hier auch für für den
Input ja
Ich muss das noch richtig nennen
Okay aber prinzipiell macht er das
Ist eigentlich egal
Ist eigentlich wurscht wir haben uns ja gerade im Deepark in der in der Konsole ausguckt
Dass es prinzipiell richtig ist was drin steht
Ach so ja aktuell geht ja nur an A
Wie kann ich ihn jetzt checken ob Keycode in einer speziellen Range ist
Kann man kann man JavaScript irgendwie Ranges anlegen irgendwie sowas
Also ich meine was gehen würde wäre in Regex zu machen
Sowas hier nach so sowas in der Richtung irgendwie Matches
Match
Da hat er irgendwas complete in Match
Könnte man quasi sagen wobei das nicht schön ist ich würde eigentlich gerne bei Keycodes bleiben
Anstatt da jetzt irgendwelche Regex Dinge zu machen
Also könnte man ja quasi sagen wir wollen Matchen von A bis 10 von 0 bis 0 bis 9
Und
Case insensitiv
If Keycodes ungleich als ja ich weiß aber da müsste ich ja die ganzen Keycodes eintragen
Das will ich ja nicht
Das soll er gefällig selbst machen
Keycode gleich
Deswegen habe ich mir den noch gespeichert
Nennen wir erstmal Key
Ja das ist keine schlechte Idee
Wobei ich das hier auf jeden Fall filtern müsste weil sonst drückt dann da irgendwie einer
Keine Ahnung auf seiner mongolischen Tastatur irgendwie was was ich da nicht haben will
Das wird jetzt so erstmal funktionieren
Dass wir mal weiter kommen
Achso ja und wir sollten gucken dass es auch wirklich nur ein
Ein Zeichen ist
So und jetzt müssen wir uns auch überlegen wie wir den ganzen Krempel richtig anzeigen
Und dafür können wir ja offensichtlich immer hier den Kram verwenden weil
Er ist der Meinung das ist jetzt objekt objekt
Das heißt dafür brauchen wir jetzt
Quasi so einen
Sich jedes mal updaten das Feld
Wo war die Formatierung für das Input
Für das Input Feld machen
So also sprich
Achso
Ich bin ja auch blöd da muss ich jetzt immer noch was ausdenken wie nennen wir das denn jetzt
Input
Irgendwas
Irgendwas Input
Hotkey Input Format
Gut und da drin
Ok wir gucken mal wir gucken erst mal ob das theoretisch funktioniert
Turn
Was mache ich denn da
Sollte jetzt wieder was ordentliches drin stehen
Was habe ich wieder irgendwo irgendwo in den Komma oder so vergessen es ist alter JavaScript
Please
Es liegt auf jeden Fall drin
Ach hier
Nee
Was ist da schon wieder verkehrt JavaScript
Sieht es irgendjemand wo ich was vergessen habe
Wo habe ich denn wieder was vergessen
Ich weiß woran es liegt ich habe es hier oben schon mal
Oh man bin ich doof
Ich habe das hier oben schon mal das muss hier rein
Debated
Achso ja Moment ich muss das ja noch ändern
Ich muss ja mal HTML jetzt noch sagen
Dings Form
Wie habe ich es genannt
Hotkey Input Format
Alter was willst du
JavaScript ich kriege Anfälle
Wo ist denn das Problem jetzt schon wieder
Was
Muss man da vielleicht Klammern dahinter machen oder so
Was was genau ist dein Problem jetzt
Wenn ich das weg mache ist das doch okay oder
Nee Moment
Ah
Oh man
Das ist eine Qual teilweise
Okay
Okay das funktioniert ich bin beruhigt das funktioniert
Jetzt muss man das nur noch ordentlich formatieren und dann
Können wir es zum Sorber schicken meine Güte
Fehlen es kommen nach der
Das sieht man nicht wenn man da drauf klickt
Okay so wie können wir das jetzt ordentlich
Formatieren
Wir haben jetzt ja hier diesen ganzen Mist
In dieser Form drin stehen
Wie formatieren wir das jetzt also wir wollen ja
Als Output sowas hier haben
Plus B oder so zum Beispiel
Sowas wollen wir hier
Je nachdem was da eingetippt wird
Also
VSCode für Visual Studio für JS
Warum machen wir das eigentlich nicht
Die letzten Streams haben wir immer
Aber es gibt in Visual Studio Code gemacht
Weiß auch nicht warum ich das jetzt gerade
Visual Studio mach
Okay wie formatieren wir das jetzt ordentlich
Also man könnte
Könnte sowas hier machen
Template String ist jetzt ja neu
Bleeding Edge
Ja was ich glaube Shit
Sowas hier nach dem Motto
Wegen dem Backend ja aber das
Die Version 1 haben wir auch
Das Front an den VSCode gemacht
Skiller das ist mir zu umständlich das muss bestimmt noch irgendwie schöner gehen
Also ich meine
Ich mein das nahelinks was wir einfachlich sagen ist
Dass ich hier quasi sage Hotkey
Control
Control wenn Control gesetzt ist
Dann machen wir
Control plus
Als String
Wenn nicht dann nicht
Aber das ist doch hässlich oder
Also ich meine es sollte prinzipiell schon mal
Funktionen wenn ich jetzt reingehe und Control drücke
Steht Control plus da
Seht ihr und es funktioniert auch
Vom Prinzip her
So
Würde die Hotkeys in ein Error speichern
Und dann einfach oh das ist das ist eine schöne Idee
Das ist eine schöne Idee
Dann heißen die Dinge auch gleich richtig
Wobei das nimmt sich nicht so viel
Ich meine wenn ich jetzt
Wenn ich jetzt einen Error machen will
Also irgendwie was ich temp
So wenn ich da jetzt Dinge reinschreiben will
Was würde ich denn da reinschreiben
Da würde ich jetzt ja auch wieder Hotkey
Da würde da eine Falls drinnen stehen
Was könnte man da draus machen
Damit ein Hotkey Keycode
Das heißt ich könnte
Ich filter jetzt einfach alles raus was
Ne dann weiß ich aber immer nicht mal was
Das gewesen ist
Also ich müsste jetzt hier schon gucken
Also ich muss so was hier machen
Im Prinzip
Ich muss im Prinzip so was machen
Oder gibt es in Javascript so was wie
In C Sharp Name of
Das ich quasi sagen kann
Ich mache jetzt mal die C Sharp Style
So was hier
Und das dann nur wenn das true ist
Genau Tommy
Wir sind gerade auf die gleiche Idee gekommen
Da fällt mir gerade keine
Gescheite Idee
Also ich meine so funktioniert das ja
Aber das ist halt
Das sieht wieder
Aber nachdem das da unten schon hässlich aussieht
Mal was da oben auch noch mal hässlich
Wir können uns ja dann überlegen was schön machen
Also sagen wir jetzt hier erstmal
Okay mal was nochmal mit Control
Dann
Du hast keine Ahnung von
Programmieren aber das hier ist unterhaltsam
Das ist schön wenn dir das gefällt
Vielleicht
Vielleicht hast du ja irgendwie eine Idee
Oder wenn es dich interessiert
Ich meine
Wenn man
So die beste Motivation
Was zu lernen wenn es an interessiert
Ist eigentlich immer wenn man
Vor irgendeinem Problem steht
Und sich überlegt wie könnte man das jetzt lösen
Dann stehst du hier irgendwann mal vor einem Problem
Und sagst hier jetzt muss ich auch JavaScript Zeug basteln
Oh jetzt werden aber die
Oh
Vom Prefixout
Wie soll ich das eigentlich
Aussprechen
Prefixout oder Prefixer
UT oder
Jetzt sag mal wie das richtig ist
Jetzt wird es hier krass was er
Geschrickt hat
Was macht das hier überhaupt
Flag
Hotkey Control also es ist dann
Flag True oder False
Name Control
Ach das ist doch ganz hübsch
Wobei das auch nicht viel kürzer wird
Dann filtern wir nur die
Die mit dem
Nee das funktioniert nicht
Dann ist ja key
Achso weil Flag hier schon auf True ist
Okay
Dann sind alle nur noch drinnen die auf True sitzen
Und dann sagen wir
Und dann mappen wir uns die
Dann schmeißen wir die Flag wieder raus
Und danach joinen wir es mit einem Plus
Kann man machen
Aber ist das wirklich so viel schöner
Als so
Ist das Programm kostenlos
Ganz auf GitHub
Ach Visual Studio Code ist auch kostenlos
Und Visual Studio selbst
Die Community Edition ist auch kostenlos mittlerweile
Aber ich muss sagen
Das ist eine schicke Idee hier
Die Würze
So
Warum rückst du das jetzt so scheiße ein
Visual Studio mach keinen Scheiß
Ah da macht das weil das
Komma wahrscheinlich fehlt
Nee
Oder macht das
Das macht er weil das Komma fehlt
Shift
Control
Win
Bleib da
Filter
Also ich finde es
Ich finde es hübsch
Bester Name
Übrigens immer Temp
Alles Temp nennen
Achso ja klar
Geht ja auch nicht
Keycode
Aha
Nice
Moment
Moment was war das
Achso
Vielleicht sollten wir die
Denken doch richtig nennen
Aber das gefällt mir
Das ist ganz schön
Das ist ganz hübsch
Control Alt
Shift A
A Reset
Das ist echt nice
Okay das funktioniert gut
So
Und jetzt brauchen wir nur noch Keycode
To Character
JS Keycode
To Jar
Get Character value from
Keycode
From Jarcode Aha
String from Jarcode
Weil JavaScript
Dieses Einrücken
Ich krieg die Krise
Origin Studio
In Ruhe
Aber ich mein
Das funktioniert
Was das
Was ist das
Das kommt
Das kommt wenn der Keycode 0 ist
A
Einrückung
Kann man da
Wenn es 0 ist
Dann wollen wir
Falls haben und wenn es nicht 0 ist
Umgedreht
Das jetzt besser funktioniert
Ja okay
Funktioniert besser
Ja nice
Nice
Guck jetzt
Jetzt können wir
Keys Capture
Also wenn es jetzt irgendeiner als Hotkey haben will
Sagen wir zum Beispiel er möchte
Control Alt Z
Bam funktioniert
Das ist cool
Hotkey Punkt
Key wird nicht funktionieren
Weil wir speichern uns den Key ja nicht
Wir speichern uns ja nur den Keycode
Ich weiß
Wie schön finde ich es irgendwie auch nicht
Vor allem das hier nicht
Okay ich probiere das jetzt nochmal kurz aus
Wie ich es am Anfang machen wollte
Also sagen wir das hier Hotkey
Dann müssen wir es gleich noch zum Server übertragen
Da bin ich mal gespannt wie das funktioniert
Hotkey Alt wenn das gesetzt ist
Dann soll das Alt sein
Gibt es, sagt mal
Gibt es in Javascript so einen Operator
Wo ich sagen kann
Also ich meine es gibt ja so einen
So einen Tenary Operator
Den gibt es ja fast jeder im Programmiersprache
Also sprich dass man sagen kann
Also quasi in If-Else
In Kurzform
Wenn Hotkey Alt true ist
Dann nehme ich den Text
Ansonsten nehme ich keinen Text
Gibt es einen Operator wo ich sagen kann
Also ohne das Else
Was ist hier der Unterschied zwischen
Key und Keycode
Der Character
Wobei auch nicht so richtig
Das ist halt Javascript Logik
Und Keycode ist halt der
So wie der ASCII Code
Was wahrscheinlich nicht 100% stimmt
In Key steht dann zum Beispiel
Auch ein großes A drin
Obwohl der Keycode 57 ist
Was keinen Sinn ergibt
Weil 57 ein kleines A ist
Aber Javascript da müssen wir uns schon mal
Keine Gedanken darüber machen
Kann man hier sowas machen
Du oder oder das
Nee
Mann das ist klar das Tantur weil das erste
Ach das ist erlaubt
Das darf man weglassen oder was
Und ernsthaft
Darf man das wirklich weglassen
Das macht es aber auch nicht schöner
Ja mit false ja mit false
Brauchen wir es nicht
Brauchen wir es ja mit true
Also könnte man es quasi sagen
Not alt
Oder oder alt
Oh das ist durch die Brust ins Auge
Ja genau die gleiche Idee hatte ich auch
Scheiße ey wenn das jetzt funktioniert
Das ist das hässlichste was ich glaube ich
Seit gesehn hab ja
Ok mal gucken ob das funktioniert
Fuck es funktioniert
Javascript
MonkaS
Aber richtig
Nice nice
Control
Vielleicht fände uns einer
Ein paar schöneres ein
Shift
Das ist ja so schön
So eklig
Shift
Win
Win alt
So und als letztes
Brauchen wir das ganze noch
Wenn not
Keycode
Oder
Nee
Einfach nur Keycode
Weil wenn Null
Dann sollte er doch nichts anzeigen
Oder
Das soll schöner sein als
Nach ich weiß nicht
Mir gefällt beides nicht so richtig
Ja geht
Ja
Das ist sehr schön das ist
Ein nicees Javascript
Ist das
Moment
Ich bin ja auch dumm
Das ist immer noch das gleiche
Ich wollte nämlich gerade sagen das kann überhaupt nicht funktionieren
Wat
Oh nee
Das funktioniert doch nicht
Das funktioniert doch doch nicht
Wir haben uns die ganze Zeit das falsche angeguckt
Lol
Ok
Also
Also doch
Bam
Es wird immer verschönern
Das ist ja immer mehr gerade
Ich glaube ich bleib doch bei der Error Lösung
Moment
Das ist das gleiche Problem
Oh krass
Nein nein ein nicees Javascript Code
Ist das
Oh habe ich das Plus hier irgendwo vergessen
Ok ich glaube wir bleiben wirklich bei der Error Lösung
Aber es funktioniert
Alles funktioniert
Also wir können jetzt sagen
Also wir können jetzt den Escape Reset
Und auch wir können den ganzen Cremple jetzt Capture
Also wenn wir mal Windows
Taste muss natürlich wieder reinklicken
Control und keine Ahnung
M
Funktioniert sehr schön
Kann man
Slate Strings
Zeilen und Brüche machen? Wahrscheinlich nicht
Die sind dann mit drinne
Da muss es doch irgendwas schöneres geben
Da muss es doch irgendwas
Ich weiß nicht
Gibt es denn sowas wie Nameoff in Javascript
Was bevor sie fort
Ja ja ja ist gut
Ja genau
Moment was
Ja das ist typisch Javascript
Da basteln sie eine eigene Funktion die so heißt
Und sagen das ist jetzt genauso wie vorher
Moment
Ich hab ne Idee
Kann das sein?
Warte Google Chrome und Chromium
Moment
Google
So viel Browser
Chrome
Firefox
Und jetzt haltet euch fest Edge
Und Internet Explorer
Und
Hab ich sonst noch was drauf
Und Opera
Und
Hab ich noch irgendwas
Safari
Nee ich glaub sonst hab ich keine Browser mehr zu bieten
Wie war
Nee hab ich auch nicht drauf
Was könnte ich noch drauf haben
Ich glaub das wars
Schonmal Qt Browser getestet
Wenn man auf Tastaturbedienung steht ist das ganz nice
So jetzt haben wir alles
Jetzt haben wir alles auf
Wir brauchen die plus nicht
Wir machen sie gleich wieder zu
Wisst ihr Edge ist so ein typischer Fall
Ist eigentlich ganz gut
Aber nicht
So geil dass man
Chrome und Firefox nicht mehr verwenden will
Ram ist am schwitzen
Ram ist
Wollen wir mal gucken
Wenn der Ram schwitzt
Einfach mal
8 Gigabyte weg
Einfach mal 8 Gigabyte
Ich mein es ist jetzt ja nicht so dass wir wahnsinnig viel auf hätten
Ja
Links
Naja
Wenn gar nichts anderes mehr geht
Aber
Man beachtet ja auch mal wieder
3 Netzwerkanschlüsse
Aber ist doch eigentlich ganz nice
Wie man einfach im Idle 11% braucht
Aber 8 Gigabyte
Ich mein wir haben im Endeffekt nicht
Nicht viel auf
Ok mal gucken wie viel wir haben
Auf
Ok mal gucken wie viel
Ram frei wird wenn ich den
Krams hier zumache
Nix das sind tatsächlich
Die Browser die den Kram
Fressen
Geil
Wir gucken mal
Man kann sich das doch irgendwie anzeigen lassen
OBS frisst
Visual Studio frisst
Der Anti Malware Service frisst
Und Krams fressen
Tja so sind halt auch mal Ratsfahrt
Zwei zu lange 8G weg
Für nix für wirklich nix
Ok
Es gab gerade noch eine Frage zum Browser
Was benutzt du lieber Chrome oder Firefox
Beides
Da muss ich ein bisschen ausholen zu
Prinzipiell
Benutze ich lieber Chrome
Aber
Eine Sache die gibt es für
Chrome nicht und das ist die
Die Leiste hier oben
Jetzt werdet ihr euch natürlich denken wieso
Chrome hat doch auch eine Leiste oben
Naja das ist ein ganz schöner Unterschied
Die Leiste von Firefox
Durchsucht standardmäßig
Favoriten
History
Suchergebn
Alles im Endeffekt
Wo ich mal jemals gewesen bin
Die standardmäßige
Leiste von Chrome macht das nicht
Die macht das eh nur gut für Seiten
Die ich oft besuche und in letzter Zeit besucht habe
Und es gibt für Chrome
Kein Addon
Was das so schön hinkriegt wie Firefox
Und so gut integriert
Es gibt so ein paar Startseiten Addons
Die ähnliche Sachen machen
Aber das ist
Not even close zu der Leiste von
Firefox
Deswegen verwende ich an sich vom Browser her
Chrome lieber, aber dank
Der Leiste und das ist eigentlich wirklich das Einzige
Ist Firefox nämlich immer noch
Mein Lieblings Browser
Was läuft bei dir auf
Der Firewall? PF Sense oder IP Fire?
Was sagt ihr zu Router OS?
Also früher hatte ich
IP Fire, ganz früher, das ist schon eine ganze
Weile her. Jetzt aktuell
Hab ich Open Sense, das ist gerade
Open Sense, Open Sense kommen auch gleich heraus
Und
Allerdings werde ich das
Und das passt, ist eigentlich witzig, dass du das gerade sagst
Das werde ich jetzt demnächst ablösen
Durch eine Mikrotik
Durch eine Mikrotik Router auf dem
Router OS läuft
Ich habe eine Idee
Ich wollte es gerade nochmal ausprobieren
Ah
Wo ist denn das Problem?
Warum kann ich denn kein Objekt zurückgeben?
Hm
Moment
Das funktioniert?
Das funktioniert nicht
Das ist ja doof ey
Das gefällt mir alles nicht
Alter, was ist das für Musik?
Wenn sie da immer labern müssten, da
Zwischen
Moment
Ich blicke gerade immer wo
So
Muss man sowas die Name aufgeben?
Object Keys
Ja
Hey, das ist keine schlechte Idee
Warte mal, da kann man doch was draus machen, oder?
Object Keys
Hotkey
Was, was kommt denn da raus?
Das muss ich mir jetzt mal ausgeben lassen
Vielleicht können wir das ein bisschen verschönern
Achso, das sind nur die Keys
Ja, okay
Das bringt mir ja nichts
Ach, das ist doch
Wirklich ey
Okay, dann lasse ich es erstmal so
Wir lassen jetzt erstmal die
Da müssen wir uns aber noch was ausdenken
Ich kann ja mal schreiben
Return, Temp
Temp ist bester Variablename
Dichtgefolgt von I und J und X
Irgendwelche Elektro-Bros
Hier
Nope
Gebrauchtes Ostteloskop
Oh, da hast du Glück, also die Dinge
Das ordentliche Ostteloskop ist brutal
Als teuer
Da kannst, also für ein richtig gutes kannst du
Fünfstellig ausgeben
Aber vierstellig kannst du auch
Wahrscheinlich auch was Gutes kriegen, aber ich weiß nicht
Ob die Dinger drunter was taugen
Das ist Schweine teuer, der Kram
Aber ich kann da leider nichts zu sagen, großartig
So, und wir müssen uns das nächste Mal dann irgendwann überlegen
So wie man das hier noch ein bisschen schöner macht, das ist hässlich
So, jetzt probiere ich den Kram nochmal kurz
Zum Säuber zu schicken
Hast du das Memebot nicht
Zu E3 angefangen? Ja, zwei Wochen
Lang, bis es funktioniert hat für mich
Und danach habe ich den weitergemacht
Und jetzt machen wir das mal ordentlich, sodass man das auch mal veröffentlichen kann
So
Moin, Panzer
Übrigens
Danke wieder für die ganzen Follows, ich gucke noch mal schnell rein
Und zwar
Der ist dann hier neu am Start heute, der Gamecrafter
Sir
Van Depper
Chef 08
Gorgor
Brauer Berg
Nicht Brauer, Brauer Berg
Gemutzter
Wärtsacht
Whiteline 58
XL Darion
Und Ten Jutsch
Und der MrBeasy ist auch am Start
Moin, okay
Jetzt muss ich mal kurz in mich gehen, jetzt wollen wir die ganzen Krämpel
An den Säuber schicken
Ja
Okay
Also
Wir haben die richtigen Daten hier drinnen stehen
Also die richtigen hier in unserem
Hotkey
Forms
Da müssen wir jetzt unsere
Send Funktion rein
Upload
Und jetzt müssen wir
Trick 17 machen
Weil
So wie ich das jetzt sehe, ist das hier eine ganz normale
Teil von unserer Form
Der mit Uploaded wird
Und
Es würde
Quasi
Das hier mit Uploaded werden
Also sprich das was wir für das
Ups
Das was wir für die
Anzeige auch ausgeben
Also das würde mit Uploaded werden
Das heißt
Wir müssen es jetzt aus dem Form
Aus der Form
Beim Uploaden wieder löschen
Wenn ich es finde
Alter wo ist es denn
Da, wir müssen es wieder löschen
Und dann müssen wir wieder
Ja wir müssen es wieder löschen
Und dann wieder hinzufügen und zwar
Als
Ähm
Ja halt
Als wie es hier oben drinnen definiert ist
Also das heißt vor dem Upload
Sagen wir jetzt hier
Form Data
Remove
Delete
Und das Ding heißt glaube ich
Einfach
Nur
Was haben wir da? Name, Text, Text
To Speech
Hotkey habe ich wahrscheinlich einfach nur genannt
Ok das löschen wir jetzt
Und dann
Fügen wir es wieder hinzu
Allerdings
Nicht das was ursprünglich
Drinnen stand
Sondern
Unsere
Die Details die wir gespeichert haben
So und das können wir jetzt nicht einfach so anhängen
Alter so einfach wird das wahrscheinlich
Als Jason in einer Form
Nicht wirklich
Kapieren vermute ich mal
Und umwandeln
Aber wir können das mal ausprobieren, ich glaube aber nicht dass es
Funktionieren wird
Das würde mich sehr wundern wenn das geht
Hallo wie gehts der Katz
Der gehts wieder besser, der Katz ging es richtig schlecht
Zwei Wochen lang
Und ich hab die ja erst ein halbes Jahr
Der Katz ging es richtig schlecht
Die hat rumgekotzt die ganze Zeit
Ähm
Deswegen bin ich gestern auch rumgerannt
Hab geguckt ob sie wieder kotzt hat sie aber nicht
Wir waren irgendwie gefühlt fünf waren beim Tierarzt
Weil die
Hatte quasi eine Woche nichts gefressen
Nachdem sie so viel rumgekotzt hat mal
Und ich habe
Ich habe dann immer auch versucht so Kleinzeug zu geben
Und sie wollte nicht, sie wollte nicht, da waren wir beim Tierarzt
Und da hat sie erst mal noch
Eine Infusion gekriegt
Die ist auch hier älter, die hat ja auch irgendwelche
Bisschen Nierenprobleme
Und Infusion gekriegt
Dann hat sie noch
Abozitanregerzeug gespritzt gekriegt
Und also Massigzeug
Und seit gestern
Also quasi seit zweieinhalb oder fast drei Wochen
Wo sie jetzt kaum was gefuttert hat
Nichts bis wenig
Seit gestern hat sie wieder angefangen
Aber natürlich mit Trockenfutter
Weil meine Katz die futtert ja am liebsten Trockenfutter
Ja sie hat keine guten Zähne
Und sonst was, aber Trockenfutter
Muss, was auch immer
Ja
Und gestern hat sie wieder angefangen
Zu fressen
Und heute hat sie schon deutlich mehr Hunger
Heute waren wir noch mal beim Tierarzt
Der hat noch mal eine Infusion gekriegt und noch mal ein bisschen Schmerzmittel
Und gegen Entzündung und
Geduld und alles, die hat eh jetzt
Voll gepumpt
Mit Zeug
Und anscheinend hat sie wieder Hunger
Und jetzt muss ich bloß gucken, dass sie nicht zu viel frisst
Weil sonst kommt sie gleich wieder
So, also das wird so wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren
Also wenn ich einfach da das Jason Ding hinten dran hänge
Das glaube ich nicht, dass es funktioniert
Aber wir können uns das ja mal angucken
Wir machen da jetzt erstmal einen String draus
Um mal zu gucken
Wie alt ist da eine Katze jetzt?
Das weiß man nicht so genau
Es gibt wieder eine Katze
Ja, ich hatte jetzt ja
Nachdem die Alte gestorben ist, hatte ich jetzt
Ja keine
Ich kanns doch mal zeigen, ich hab doch hier auf Twitter immer
Das ist die neue
Also die neue, die hab ich jetzt seit einem halben Jahr
Da guckt sie so grimmig, die guckt eigentlich gar nicht so grimmig
Aber wie gesagt, die ist
Das ist noch ein Tag, wo sie nicht viel gefuttert hat
Das ist noch vorgestern
Da war sie noch ein bisschen müde
Da liegt sie neben mir
Das ist die neue
Was auch geil ist, Katzenlogik
Super bequem hier, aber wo sitzen wir da neben?
Ja, das ist sie
Das ist die neue
Ihr werdet nicht glauben
Hier, da hat sie noch gefressen
Da hat sie noch gefressen
Mau, gib her
So, und die Alte
Die Alte kennt ihr ja noch
Das ist auch die neue
Gleich breit gemacht
Das ist die Alte
Die war so niedlich, die Alte
Wo sie hier meinen
Schrank inspiziert hat
Ja, das ist hier, wo sie eingeschläfert wurde
Das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an
Da ist sie mit
Mit Amiibo am Start
Es gibt sogar irgendwo einen
Auf meinem Bullshit-Zweitschannel
Auf dem ich eigentlich nie was hochlade
Alter, MonkaS
Ja, das ist die Alte
Ja, das ist die neue
Die Frage, warum ich mir eine Alte geholt habe
Weil die gemütlicher sind
Und weil so wenige Leute Alte Katzen haben wollen
Und ich meine, das ist doch doppelt bescheuert
Wenn du quasi eine
Wenn du schon eh eine Alte Katze bist
Und nicht mehr 20 Jahre alt wirst
Also noch zusätzlich 20 Jahre alt wirst
Und dann noch die letzten paar Jahre im Tierheim hocken
Das ist doch kacke
Und außerdem sind Alte Katzen
Da weißt du, was du kriegst
Darf man nicht unterschätzen
Du weißt, was Sache ist
Also sprich
Wenn die schlecht drauf ist
Dann weißt du, das ist anscheinend
Immer so
Und wenn die gut drauf ist
Du weißt, was du kriegst bei einer Alten Katze
Die macht von heute auf morgen nicht mal auf einmal was anderes
Ja, wir haben die auch aus dem Tierheim
Wir waren
3 oder 4 Wochen
Waren wir immer wieder da
Haben die besucht, also sprich
Die hat es ja schon dran gewöhnt
Okay, ich wollte jetzt mal gucken
Ob das jetzt
Was da überhaupt ankommt
Shortcut
Wir dürfen das übrigens nicht
Shortcut nennen, sondern
Wir müssen es
Nehmen
Wie kommt das Ding auf die Idee, dass es
Was gibt, was Shortcut heißt
Ich muss mal
Neu
Compile so an
Das
Die Autovervollständigung
Die Intelligenzgeschichte
Okay
Mal gucken, ob es jetzt funktioniert
Hä?
Ah, ich bin in der falschen Datei
Oh, da bin ich bescheuert
Ich bin ja auch dumm
Falsche Meme Datei
Das ist die vom WPF Frontend gewesen
Da ist der richtige
Oh, Shortcut weg.
So, aber das wird jetzt nicht funktionieren.
Das muss ich schon noch ein bisschen aufpröseln.
So, Bildchen.
Oh, mega Lul.
Upload.
Oh ne, uiuiuiuiuiui.
Böööö.
Ach so, ja, äh, moment. Ich muss die Datenmark nochmal wegschmeißen.
So. Muss ich den Kran, muss ich die Tabels neu anlegen?
Muss man Windows neu aufsetzen? Scheisse.
Ja. Feet's Batman.
Warum?
Ich bin doch schon ewig, wenn man neu installiert.
Eigentlich hält es doch ganz gut mittlerweile.
Wie hat das jetzt funktioniert?
Ähm...
Ich hätte mal einen Breakpoint setzen sollen, weil...
What?
Breakpoint.
Break, Break, Breakpoint.
Schlüsselstudio-Brepoint.
Undefied.
Ja...
Das war klar, dass das so nicht funktioniert.
Das wär auch zu schön gewesen, ne?
Wenn wir quasi einfach ein Jason-Objekt
in der Form hätten hochpumpen können
und der hätte es sich dann quasi übersetzt so.
Boah, das wär nice gewesen, aber es funktioniert nicht.
Irgendwas funktioniert, nur Blue Screen.
Vielleicht hast du ja auch Hardware-Probleme
und das ist am Windows 9 installieren, ist gar nicht behoben.
Okay.
Hotkey.
So, jetzt muss man komische ASP.NET-Syntax einhalten,
dass der auch erkennt,
dass im Frontend Hotkey auch im Backend
bei der Memeklasse
Hotkey gemeint ist.
Das ist ein bisschen...
Schwierig, wie man den ganzen Kram nennen muss.
Also ich glaube, man macht das mit einem Unterstrich
oder mit einem Punkt
dazwischen das Ganze
zu trennen.
Jason-Stringify, der bringt ja nichts.
Bringt ja nichts.
Er kommt als Jason auf dem Server an,
aber der weiß ja an der Stelle nicht,
was er damit machen soll.
Also guck, das ist die Methode,
die aufgerufen wird,
wenn man die Form abschickt.
Also sprich, man kriegt das File,
also,
ich hab's jetzt hier grad nicht auf,
im Endeffekt das Bild kriegt man
hier in dieser Files Collection
und man kriegt quasi schon ein fix und fertig gepasstes Model,
sprich, das passt dann ja aus der Form raus
hier rein.
Das heißt, muss ich nicht mehr selbst machen.
So, und der hat jetzt natürlich keine Ahnung,
dass wenn in der Form
wenn in der Form jetzt auf einmal hier
ein Jason-Ding drin ist
für Hotkey,
dass er das dann da irgendwie reinschreiben soll.
Das checkt er nicht.
Also ich meine, mit Stringify
funktioniert's an der Stelle,
aber das wollen wir ja nicht, wir wollen ja,
dass es ein Meme-Objekt, also ein Hotkey-Objekt
ist später.
Also wir können das an der Stelle
mit Stringify machen, aber das bringt uns am Ende nichts.
Da haben wir jetzt halt einen String vor,
da müsste ich den String dann quasi auf Serverseite
wieder parsen und ein Objekt draus erstellen.
Was geht, was aber doppelt gemoppelt ist,
weil das kann ja ASP.NET für mich machen.
Wenn ich den Krams
ordentlich
poster an, an den Server.
Ah, Moment, ich hab den
Project-Point vergessen.
Warum ist es undefined?
Der Rest hat funktioniert. It's It's Hotkey.
Oh, oh, gucken wir mal,
warum das jetzt nicht funktioniert.
Groß und Kleinschreibung wird es wahrscheinlich nicht dran liegen.
Achso, ja, ist klar, warum es nicht funktioniert,
weil ich kein Hotkeys eingetragen habe.
Haha, eigentlich richtig dumm.
Natürlich funktioniert das nicht.
Doch, es hätte doch funktionieren müssen.
Wartet mal an.
Also zumindest so müsste es funktionieren.
Ja, ja, so funktioniert es.
So ist Ctrl B, aber das wollen wir nicht.
Also wir wollen es hinterher,
aber wir wollen es hinterher.
Das wollen wir nicht.
Also wir wollen es hier nicht alles stringen.
So, und warum genau hat das jetzt Stringy Fight nicht funktioniert?
Das ist auch so was, das kannst du im Programmier-Stream sagen.
Warum hat das Stringy Fight nicht funktioniert?
Wie sich das anhört.
Also ich fasse an wie irgendwas Unanständiges.
Und heute schon Stringy Fight?
Warum geht das nicht?
Ah, ich snoop, weil es das falsche Objekt ist.
Ah, ja, ja, soll ich gucken auf den Chat?
Wahrscheinlich habe ich das längst schon erkannt.
Oh, ich schnaufe das mal.
Ja guck, das funktioniert jetzt gut, so, ne, aber wir können das ja anders machen, wir
können das ja sp.net für uns parsen lassen, alles.
Und zwar können wir jetzt sagen, an der Stelle, anstatt das von JSON zu Object zu JSON und
zurück, äh, wo sind wir, können wir das einfach als Formdata verpacken, anstatt als JSON-Streamer,
dann sollte das auch so funktionieren.
Ich probiere jetzt an der Stelle einmal noch aus, ob das vielleicht tatsächlich, ob er
vielleicht das doch hinkriegt.
Wir haben es in der falschen Klasse gemacht, aber das vielleicht doch hinkriegt, dass das
direkt zu parsen, aber ich glaub's ja nicht.
Dann müssen wir nochmal die Datenbank wegschmeißen.
Was soll das Meme-Tool nachher können, beziehungsweise wofür ist das, ich zeig's dir gleich, ähm,
oh, ich hab den Breakpoint wieder vergessen, so ein Noob, äh, warum mach ich den Breakpoint
auch immer weg?
Aber in der Ausgabe soll es hier irgendwo drin stehen, steht's aber nicht, hier sollte
es stehen, hier, das kann er nicht parsen, das heißt, ich muss das ordentlich als Formdata
schicken.
Was das Meme-Tool macht, ähm, du kannst hier, holst das Webinterface, so, ähm, du hast
hier eine Webinterface, das kannst du dir auf deinem zweiten Rechner anmachen, oder
auf deinem Hauptrechner, oder auf deinem Tablet, oder sonst was, dort kannst du irgendwelche
dir beliebigen Bildchen hochladen, was du willst, ist eigentlich egal, kannst du einen
Text eingeben, kannst du einen Text zu Speech mit schöner Reap-Stimme machen, sowas hier
zum Beispiel, was du willst, dann uploadest du das Ganze, kannst den Hotkey angeben, also
sowas wie, äh, Control, was weiß ich, was braucht man, Control-0 oder sowas, uploadest
du das Ganze, und dann kannst du das als Overlay einblenden lassen, und es ist nicht etwa
einfach nur Overlay, was dich aus Spielen oder so rausschmeißt, du willst sehen, guck,
das kann man, man sieht es jetzt nicht richtig, hier kannst du durchklicken durch das Bild,
und auch wenn man das, also selbst wenn das angezeigt wird, das crappt nicht den Fokus,
und der Vorteil dazu, also du brauchst dieses Webinterface um schnell Bildchen aufzumachen
gar nicht, weil du kannst dir einen Shortcut vergeben, Big Brain, und dann kannst du Control-0
drücken, wenn du Control-0 drückst, also jetzt hab ich geklickt, dann geht das Bild
auf.
In der ersten Version funktioniert das auch schon alles, aber wir machen das Webinterface
jetzt ein bisschen schöner, ja, und das hat einen riesen Vorteil im Vergleich zu, ähm,
reine Lösung über OBS, dass du die Bilder selbst siehst, wir bauen auch noch was ein,
dass falls das jemand auch nur im OBS machen will, und dass du halt ein paar andere Sperenzchen
rein machen kannst, wie Text zu Speech und sowas, die OBS nicht kann, und vor allem,
also das Hauptfeature, warum ich es auch gebaut habe, weil ich das selbst brauche, ist, dass
man es selbst sieht, das ist die Hauptsache, weil ich hat schon so oft, die, den Fall, dass
ich was in Overlay angemacht hab und es vergessen hab, weil es halt nur im OBS drin war, und
so, ne, also da bin ich ins OBS, hab dann hier irgendwie, keine Ahnung, das Zeug angemacht,
kannst ja auch mit dem Hotkey machen, und mir ist nicht aufgefallen, dass ich die ganze
Zeit an den Kackpapageiern hab, weil ich's selbst seh' ihn halt nicht.
Reis auf Milchreis, ja, ähm, doch, paar, paar Leute checken's mittlerweile.
Telekom, was sich hinter dem Layer versteckt, ähm, Telekom-Logo, und Telekom-Logo, wo die
wir auslachen können, wenn wieder irgendwas nicht funktioniert.
Ich wollte sagen, dann können wir sagen, Telekom-Lol, und sowas zum Beispiel, könnt ich mir jetzt
ohne Probleme, wenn ich jetzt öfters mal sagen würde, ich würde jetzt öfters mal gerne
einblenden, Telekom-Lol, dann würd ich mir hier ein Bildchen machen, hochladen und könnt
ich per Shortcut anzeigen lassen, bam, ich würd selber sehen, ihr würdet's sehen, und
dabei könnt ich noch irgendwie einen dummen, dummen Text-to-Speech-Spruch ablassen oder
sowas.
Das macht man damit.
So, jetzt müssen wir gucken, dass der Upload funktioniert, und dazu müssen wir das Zeugs
richtig benennen, nämlich dürfen wir jetzt nicht die ganze Sache Stringy Fight hochschieben,
mal kurz chat gucken, ob ich was übersehen hab, ob der einzige, der in Memes spricht,
ja, ich weiß, wie viele Zeilen Code hat das Memetool jetzt, also die alte, kannst du gucken,
also die aktuelle Version eins, ne, die Version 0.2, wenn's hochkommt, ist ja auf GitHub,
kannste hier angucken, sieht man, sieht man aber GitHub ungefähr, wie viele Zeilen Code
das hat, steht das hier irgendwo, wir können mal mit dem Initialen Comment gucken, wie
viele da drin sind, beste Comment überhaupt, ja, ja, also es hatte Initial 600, also lass
es mal, aber da ist halt auch das Konfig-Scheiß dabei, das passt überhaupt nicht, guck mal,
so viel Konfig-Müll denn, da hat keine Ahnung, 300 oder so, und das aktuell, aktuell würde
ich sagen, hat das so, keine Ahnung, das meiste dürfte dieses JavaScript gefrickelt fürs
Frontend sein, also ich sag, keine Ahnung, 600 oder so, wenn's hoch, aber dann ist wirklich
alles dabei, 600, also inklusive CSS, JavaScript, HTML und restlichen Krams, so 600 oder sowas,
aber Line of Code ist eh keine, keine ordentliche Maßstab, deine Dokumentation ist dürftig,
welche Dokumentation, ich hab mich vorhin dabei erwischt, als ich Comments geschrieben
hab, hab ich gleich wieder abgebrochen, ja, du kannst dir, es gibt ein Archiv, wo du auch
die ganzen Programmier-Streams findest, leider nicht auf Twitch, weil man als Nonpartner
noch weniger Platz hat, quasi vergangenen Procast zu speichern, es gibt ein, einmal
gibt's einen MaxFPS.tv, kannst du machen, oder du kannst einen Wupplors.tv machen, das
ist die gleiche Seite, das ist vom Sebaro, hier sind die schnellste Seite, aber ich bin,
ich find's richtig gut und toll, dass er das gemacht hat, da hat er alle bisherigen Streams,
die er crammen konnte, mit hochgeladen, da ist alles da, die Seite braucht immer ein
bisschen, aber dann kann man sich das alles angucken, wenn man will, warum ausgerechnet
Vue.js, weil ich kein großer JavaScript-Held bin, da kann man jetzt hier sagen Twitch-Archiv,
Quatsch, das ist der aktuelle, Archiv, genau, oh, da fehlen dem Sebaro aber ein paar Sachen
hier, aber man sieht schon, es ist, das meiste ist drauf, aber wie gesagt, trotzdem, es ist
ja nice, dass er das überhaupt gemacht hat, also da wollen wir uns jetzt mal nicht beschweren,
dass jetzt quasi die letzten paar Streams fehlen, und ja, es ist quasi wie ein Elgato Stream
Deck, plus, dass man kein Elgato Stream Deck braucht und man quasi einbauen kann, was
man will, also rein software-mäßig wird's wahrscheinlich rein auf die Funktion konzentriert,
Bildchen anzuzeigen, besser als Elgato Stream Deck, allerdings ist Elgato Stream Deck ja
noch viel mehr, deswegen ist eines der Punkte, die ich mir aufgeschrieben hab, was wir in
der Zukunft noch machen werden, eine Elgato Stream Deck-Integration, hab ich nämlich
schon eine Library auf GitHub gefunden, um das ordentlich zu integrieren, so, und warum
ausgerechnet Vue.js, es gibt ja so viele JavaScript-Frameworks, ganz einfach, ich bin da kein großer JavaScript-Held,
und nachdem ich jetzt schon Anfälle krieg mit JavaScript und mit Vanilla JavaScript erst
recht, hab ich gesagt, hab ich mal geguckt, was gerade so angesagt ist JavaScript-mäßig
und das ist halt Vue.js, und ich muss sagen, damit macht's sogar halbwegs Spaß, also das
ist schon nicht schlecht, also von allen Sachen, die ich bisher verwendet hab, ist das das
beste, ich hab ja nicht so viel mit JavaScript gemacht, aber ich hab mal Ember ausprobiert,
das ist aber schon ewig, das ist absolut overloaded, extrem, da verstehst du teilweise gar nicht,
was es macht, was du schreibst, dann hab ich auch ganz kurz ein bisschen Angular ausprobiert,
bin ich überhaupt nicht mit warm geworden, React ging komplett an mir vorbei, wie gesagt,
normalerweise mach ich wenig Frontend-Geschichten, wobei ja da React ja quasi der Shit schlechthin
ist, und Vue ist toll, Vue braucht man keine extra NPM-Geschichten oder sonst was, einfach
Vue Include und auf geht's.
Contributions von dir auf dem Account, glaub ich nix, das ist ja der Account fürs Stremsorn,
na, auf dem Account nix, auf meinem privaten Account hab ich ein paar Contributions, allerdings
nix bei irgendwie großartigen, bekannten Projekten, music please, das ist ein Radinsenden,
chillstep 24 7 Livestream, chill ambient studio music, kannste auch zurückfuhlen, kannste
gucken, was es war, ja Patrick, es wär nicht schlecht, das könnte man im Separo echt mal
eins hinstellen.
So, falls ihr jetzt noch was übersehen habt, schreibt's einfach nochmal, man könnte das
ja auch auf einem Raspberry Pi laufen, also meinst du das Archiv oder was, ja die Frage
ist da eher die Anbindung, weil du musst ja Videos streamen davon, wie findest du TypeScript,
TypeScript ist super.
Ist das Stringify sicher gegen Injections, naja Stringify an sich ist mit Sicherheit
nicht sicher gegen Injections, weil du kannst ja da quasi jeglichen String reinhauen, muss
halt gucken, was du da rein haust und ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass was ich hier
fabriziert hab, ist null sicher gegen Injections und vor allem, ja absolut best practice, so
wie man es macht, ungeprüft in die Datenbank, so macht man's, so geht's, mit TFs hat jemand
was donatet, ich pack's nicht, The Haze ist am Start, keine Message, ja danke für den
Euro, falls du ne Message angegeben hast und das rumbackt, schreib's gerne auch mal in
den Chat rein, äh, die Musik grad ab, die Musik ist weg, ah geht wieder, was auch immer,
Gameboard auf dem Raspberry, nee, nee, nee, das geht nicht, das geht nicht, weil du brauchst
ja die Desktop Anwendungen dafür, ich glaube das ist, also bei den Leuten die nicht ganz,
ich muss ich vielleicht jetzt nochmal erklären, ja, für die Leute die quasi die ersten Streams
angeguckt haben, das Webfrontend, was ihr hier seht, das ist wirklich nur ein Webfrontend
für eine Desktop Anwendung, die Desktop Anwendung ist allerdings versteckt und im Hintergrund,
also guckt mal, wenn ich jetzt hier Eats anklicke im Webinterface und stellt euch mal vor,
das ist halt nicht hier auf dem gleichen Rechner, ich mach's jetzt hier nur auf dem gleichen
Rechner, damit ihr's seht, das ist dafür gedacht, um's auf dem zweiten Monitor anzumachen
während man streamt oder auf einem Tablet, so, und da klick ich, da klickt man Eats an
und dann zeigt ihr hier das Bild als Overlay und das hier ist eine Windows Desktop Anwendung,
die das anzeigt, halt versteckt, bis auf das Bild, man sieht es auch nicht in der Taskleiste
oder so, aber das ist, äh, eine stinknormale WPF Anwendung mit verstecktem Bild, was im
Endeffekt nix anderes macht, wie das jeweilige Bildchen anzeigen, deswegen kann das nicht
auf dem Raspberry laufen, weil, es muss ja auf dem Windows System laufen, weil man ja
dort streamt und dort die Bilder anzeigen lassen will, kannst du HTML, ich würd mal
sagen, es reicht, was ich kann von HTML, ah, also, geht so halbwegs, HTML ist ja auch nicht
schwer an sich, da muss ich alle paar Jahre ein bisschen gucken, was es so neues gibt
und dann ist gut, ok, jetzt können wir aber endlich mal das machen, was wir eigentlich
die ganze Zeit machen wollen, sagen wir mal, der Stream ist am rumspacken, kann das sein?
No Chill, wuah, ok, läuft wieder, es gibt schon seit einiger Zeit ein Windows 10 für
PC, ja, aber das bringt ja nix, du spielst ja nicht auf dem Raspberry, also der Raspberry
ist ja nicht dein Gaming PC, auf dem du Bildchen als Overlay anzeigen willst, also es bringt
dir in dem Fall nix, du willst ja die Overlays quasi in deinem Stream anzeigen, also sprich,
wenn du spielst und es passiert irgendwas, willst du beispielsweise einen MonkaS Overlay
anzeigen und es bringt ja nix, wenn du das auf dem Raspberry sonst wo anzeigen lässt,
du willst es ja auf dem Rechner anzeigen lassen, wo du gerade draufguckst und wo du
gerade spielst, ist auch Linux-Support geplant, naja, nachdem es eigentlich hauptsächlich
für Stream ist und für Games und es läuft unter Linux, ja, also das Webfrontend und
das, also diese ASP-Anwendung, die wird ohne Probleme unter Linux laufen, dass die Windows-Anwendung
ist halt, also die Desktop-Komponent ist halt das Problem, also man könnte das relativ
einfach auch für Linux basteln, dann müsste man halt anstatt dieser WPF-Anwendung für
die Overlay-Bildchen irgendwas mit GTK oder am besten direkt mit X oder irgendwie sowas
basteln, das wird funktionieren, mittlerweile läuft ja.NET Core ziemlich gut, also könnte
man zum Beispiel sagen, also ASP.NET, also ASP.NET Core ist und.NET Core zusammen funktioniert
wunderbar auf Linux, würde ich sogar bevorzugen unter Linux laufen zu lassen als unter Windows,
man braucht halt noch die Desktop-Anwendung für die Bilder-Overlays, kann das Tool auch
Animationen, es geht so, ich zeig dir mal die aktuelle Version, die kann nämlich noch
ein bisschen mehr, ich würd's nicht unbedingt Animationen nennen, aber sowas in der Richtung
ne, also das ist ein GIF oder so, kannst du beispielsweise hier LUL overlayen und dann
kannst du es drehen lassen, das ist die einzige Animation die's kann und wieder stoppen und
hyperlullen kannst, das war's, also so Blödsinn kann man da natürlich noch einbauen, ja
der Ziel von der Sache, die ich jetzt baue ist es erstens ordentlich zu machen, also von
der zweiten Version ist ordentlich zu machen und halt auch benutzbar ordentlich, also sprich
dass man ordentliche Shortcuts definieren kann, dass man das nicht mehr im Dateinamen
irgendwie rein machen muss, dass man ordentlich suchen kann und sowas in der Richtung, hast
du ne englische Tastatur, nö, was passiert wenn man GIFs nimmt, dann ist es ein GIF und
dann mit GIFs kannst du was richtig geiles machen, also mein normales LUL kann jeder,
LUL 3D kann auch noch jeder, aber LUL 4D, das kann nicht mehr jeder, rein, raus, Resume,
Resize, jaja das kann man alles noch machen, das ist kein Ding, aber erstmal müssen die
Basics funktionieren, so LUL 4D, das hat was Hypnotisches, so eher was meditatives wenn
man da draufklickt und man sieht ja man kann da durchklicken, das ist das wichtige daran
und dabei müssen wir eigentlich noch das hier jetzt in Schleife laufen lassen, so, genug
jetzt, ich mein wir machen heute null Progression eigentlich, ne, was braucht die Desktop Anwendung
für Ressourcen, nicht viel, das meiste fressen die Bilder die unoptimiert sind, also ich
hab ja hier Bildchen drinnen teilweise mit relativ hoher Auflösung und sowas, die fressen
ein bisschen was, aber ansonsten nicht viel, keine Ahnung, 60MB, irgendwie sowas, gucken
vielleicht sieht man das ja, also das ist jetzt ja der RAM Verbrauch hier ist ja alles
zusammen, Web Anwendung, guck mal, das ist quasi die komplette Web Anwendung plus die
Desktop Anwendung, also sprich die Desktop Anwendung ist ja für das Bildchen hier zuständig
und das braucht nicht so viel, weiß nicht ob man eben vielleicht sieht man hier irgendwie
wieviel nur die, Moment läuft das Minboard jetzt doppelt gerade, ohje, ich muss mal, ich
mach das alte mal aus, so, also, ähm, tja, wo ist denn die andere App, also die Web Anwendung
braucht halt nicht wirklich was, ich finde die andere Anwendung gar nicht um ehrlich
zu sein, keine Ahnung, zumindest wahrscheinlich, ja sieht man es hier, keine Ahnung, 70MB oder
so, also es hält sich sehr in Grenzen, ok, jetzt machen wir mal, wir wollen sagen, dass,
das da, wir wollen das hier uploaden, ach stimmt, ja das kann schon sein, klar, die läuft
hier irgendwo bei Universal Studio, wo ist sie, das ist hier bestimmt irgendwo unten
drunter, ne, wie so das da oder so, starten wir das mal ohne Debugger, äh, wo ist der
passende Knopf dafür, ist die Steuerung F5, ist es, ist es, ja das ist jetzt ohne Debugger,
hm, Web Anwendung, ja, keine Ahnung wo die Desktop Anwendung ist, die ist hier overrated,
gebated, die sieht man nicht, jetzt haben wir ohne Debugger gestartet, keine Ahnung,
ne, ne, ne, die Web Application ist das Web Interface, es gibt ja noch eine zweite, aber
das könnte, ne, ne, blödsinn, natürlich, natürlich ist es die Web Anwendung, weil,
ich ruf ja die, ich starte ja nicht beide Anwendungen, sondern ich ruf ja die zweite
aus der ersten aus, ja klar, das ist die, also guck mal, das braucht nix im Endeffekt,
nix, Anrahmen großartig, nix, das ist, das ist der Witz, 58MB, 58MB für ne, für ne
WPF Desktop Anwendung plus ne Web Anwendung mit Datenbank, 58MB, das, ähm, braucht Elektron
im Eidl, beim Hochfahren, also sprich für Elektron kannst du hier erstmal mal 200MB
drauf hauen, so wie zum Beispiel, ich zeig's euch mal, ne ich zeig's euch nicht, ist eigentlich
egal, so üblich, da hab ich schon so oft drüber rumgeflamet, guckt euch mal an zum
Beispiel, wenn ich dieses komische Nvidia Overlay anmache, was schon wieder kaputt
ist, guckt euch mal an, was das für, was das frisst hier, nein, alter, ich will jetzt
kein Nvidia Zeug installieren, ich will einfach meine Grafik Settings aufmachen, einfach
meine Grafik Settings öffnen, gut, darf ich nicht, ne, aber wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel
mit Steam oder so, Elektron Zeug braucht viel, ja, und das ist halt nix, 58MB ist absolut
top, ok, Hotkey, Hotkey, Punkt, Hotkey Control, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
so ob das jetzt klappt
so die bildchen
hallo
ich hab bestimmt so ein tag fehler oder so tritt ja klar
ja warum ist der stream schon wieder kaputt
aber ein lecker stream bei euch oder ist es mein youtube was ihr abspacht zwischendurch
ich hab keine frame drops top guck mal leute dropped frames null bei zweieinhalb stunden
das ist schon sehr nice
nice hat funktioniert
hat funktioniert also sprich ich kann es ganz abladen muss ich noch den ganzen kram
hier einstellen aber also wir müssen quasi jedes ding jetzt noch einzeln hinzufügen
und dementsprechend hier
wie oft ich den kram heute schon geschrieben habe und keycode wobei keycode müssen wir
glaube ich nee zu überlegen wie man das keycodes
ja keycode machen wir nur wenn wenn das wenn eben keycode auch was drin steht
sonst ist das nix gut jetzt laden wir den ganzen krempel hoch da haben wir das mit erreicht
was wir heute schaffen wollten dass wir nämlich shortcuts capturen können und zum server hoch
schieben ob der keycode auch funktioniert aber gehe ich mal von aus
und das muss ich mal ausblenden ja control ist gesetzt und und keycode ist 78 kommt alles
an auf dem server sehr nice das einzige was wir jetzt noch mal kurz machen ist wir stellen
das hier auf read only den hotkey input den stellen wir auf read only weil dann haben
wir keine auto vervollständigung mehr da unten da unten dran nice oder warum man jetzt
nix anzeigt weiß ich nicht das habe ich irgendwie kaputt gemacht irgendwas habe ich kaputt gemacht
er zeigt nix mehr an das eine geht das andere ist kaputt aber ja pech gehabt ich meine
sollte es hiermit eigentlich anzeigen aber das kann ich alles noch das nächste mal basteln
also prinzipiell haben wir es ja erreicht was wir heute wollten wir können sachen capturen
und ja mag nix mehr anzeigen da ist irgendwas kaputt hat man ich riss ich resette das konstell mal
wahrscheinlich speichern ich glaube der speichert das nicht weil das model nicht stimmt kannst
du mir html helfen schicke den whisper die schreibt doch im chat das ist wenn du mir
das im whisper schreibst bringt es ja keinem was ja postet das ruhig mal im chat
also nicht den ganzen html nur mal den link und so die leute können dann sich das angucken
und ich gucke erstmal dass da auch wirklich nur html dahinter ist und nicht irgendwelche
debate geschichte ich gehe mal davon aus das model wird nicht gespeichert weil die
weil das nicht in ordnung ist jetzt mit dem mit dem hotkey dabei vermute ich mal
so gut also heute fertig aber ich muss sagen ich finde das echt nice
also dass das ist echt cool hier diese geschichte mit quasi reintracken droppen
und dann capturen lassen so nach dem motto alt und x upload ja okay bild anzeigen ist
kaputt muss was nächstes mal gucken warum es sich anzeigt aber an sich ist doch echt
cool ich bin echt zufrieden mit dass wir das heute hingekriegt haben und ich meine
das doch echt nice du kannst jetzt kannst jetzt wirklich irgendwie was weiß ich allmöglichen
ist man kann sagen ob es was das oder es noch ein back ist back noch ein bisschen wenn ich
alt gr drücke zeigte mir an control plus alt hat das wichtigste kaputt gemacht noch
kann ich das ja machen noch benutzt ja keiner
zu
ja ich gucke mal was du geschrieben hast
die seite geht bei mir nicht richtig
ok also wollen wir als letzte amtshandlung noch mal dem anime fan 80 helfen mit seinem
html zeug uns jetzt für die schule machen oder für was ist das machen wir jetzt quasi
hausaufgaben oder für was ist das
jo max mal eine frage kennst du eine gute seite wo man sie schabeln kann beziehungsweise
sie ist gut erklärt ja ja ja gibt eine richtig gute seite mit der habe ich damals auch angefangen
also 2003 oder so es gibt einen also das bestimmt überhaupt nicht mal das also weitem nicht
mal das einzige ja aber was gut war ist hier das das galileo galileo open boxy scharp
das ist nicht schlecht ich habe mit ich habe mit der 2005 version 2003 version oder sowas
gelernt das ist wirklich nicht übel damit kann man auf jeden fall was anfangen ansonsten
gibt es bestimmt mittlerweile hunderttausende videos zu children sonst was auf youtube das
bestimmt viel viel besser mittlerweile als ich den krams damals gelernt habe also im
prinzip das was der travel auch gerade empfiehlt ist das gleiche nicht für die schule für
dich selbst gibt es ein beta zum testen es gab von der ersten von der ersten implementierung
eine beta version mit der man ein bisschen rumspielen konnte aber wir brauchen wahrscheinlich
noch ein bisschen mach mal facecam an wie gesagt bei einer million abos lull ok so dann
helft jetzt mal neben anima fan 80 coach ja so und was willst du da jetzt was möchtest
du genau wissen ach nee da gehört noch html dazu ne kamera und schnitt referenzen ist das
so eine so eine lebenslaufseite oder was wird das die haben das ganze buch online das buch
ist kostenlos ja das ist das gleiche was ich auch gerade gezeigt habe das ist das ist richtig
gut also wenn man wenn man was in buchform will ist das open book wirklich top was genau
programmierst du ich zeige sie ja ich starte mal die letzte version die noch funktioniert
weil die aktuelle ist gerade ein bisschen ein bisschen broken wir basteln habe ich es
denn hier wir basteln ein overlay ein programm womit man sich auf shortcut bilder auf shortcuts
legen kann und anzeigen lassen kann und ein bisschen sinnlose animation machen kann machen
ja so was da in der richtung dazu gibt es den web frontend wo du die ganzen sachen dann
hochladen kannst und shortcuts für vergeben kannst und sowas hier sagst du hier kannst
du anklicken auf dem auf dem das gerade kaputt kannst du auf dem tablet anklicken zeig dir
das bild auf deinem streaming rechner an kannst du neues bild hochladen was ich das da tech
sonst war es suchst dir einen schott shortcut aus kannst noch schöne weep text to speech
dabei machen letzte hoch klicks da an zeigt dir als overlay an im vergleich zu elgato
stream deck natürlich nicht ganz so schicke hardware logischerweise und im vergleich zu
obs ist es einfach so und auch zu elgato stream deck das was mir da gefehlt hat ist dass man
die bilder selber nicht sieht sondern nur im obs und deswegen habe ich sowas gebastelt
ok also du möchtest ich will aus dem html teil im css eine navigation mit drop down
menü machen also top down menü ist relativ einfach in html kann man hier was reinschreiben
jetzt ist das geschert kannst du jetzt auch was tippen ist das live oder ist das ist das
ein snapshot und also editiert man damit jetzt quasi zusammen an dem dokument das wäre nämlich
mal eine richtig geile sache wenn das geht oder ist es ein snapshot den ich kriege cool
das ist die seite muss man merken das cool alle zuschauer schreiben drin rum ja wenn du nicht aufpasst
copypaste dir mal ganz schnell dein dokument sonst löscht es irgendeiner oder so also und ich
mache das jetzt auch mal zu sonst pausen die irgendeine dicks rein oder so ich wäre gebannt
also nen top down in html kann man relativ einfach machen dafür kann man das irgendwie
kostenlos verwenden oder so great jupin so ich bin ich bin kein großer html profi also
kannst du ihnen kann sich select kannst du machen so irgendwie so geht das select das
schon mal den top down und dann sagst du hier drinne einfach option plupp option so da hast
ein top down das ist super easy in html top down ist wichita basic gut also wichita basic.net ist
was heißt gut es ist als mein fall ist es nicht wichita basic aber mit wichita basic.net kannst
du alles machen was du in sich haben auch machen kannst oder was du mit f schacht was mit jeder
dort net sprache machen kannst ganz ehrlich ich würde jetzt nicht mehr anfangen wichita basic
zu lernen wichita basic ist jetzt relativ tote sprache auch dort die dort net variante microsoft
wird die noch eine ganze weile supporten ja aber wenn ich was lernen würde würde ich z sharp
anfangen so und es gibt bestimmt noch 100.000 andere varianten wie man einen top down machen
kann die sharps sind übel schwierig das ist nicht schwierig brauche ich ein bisschen dran
gewöhnen aber ansonsten ist es nicht schwierig ich meine ich also die sharp hat ein paar richtig
coole sachen also wir machen jetzt mal was also ich mein ich finde ich finde es deutlich schöner
als als wichita basic aber du kannst jetzt irgendwie sowas sagen wie was weiß ich war
liste new list int und dann machst du deine liste add also kann mir keiner sagen dass das
irgendwie schwierige sündags ist 1 2 3 4 3 4 5 so und dann sagst du eine schleife hintendran
liste ausgeben item so und man kann das sieht doch also ich kann entschreiben ich meine es
ist jetzt most basic ever ja aber ich meine es ist doch nicht doch nicht doch nicht kompliziert
aus ja und was was sind sie scharp halt schön ist du kannst dann auch das geht in allen dort net
sprachen letztendlich ja du kannst zum beispiel wunderbar sagen du kannst zum beispiel richtig
schön filtern das ist auch eine sache das gibt es mittlerweile in vielen anderen sprachen auch aber
ich finde diese link geschichte in scharp ist immer noch am besten du kannst es zum beispiel
sagen ich will nur elemente haben die größer sind als drei führst du aus und hast nur noch
vier und fünf von der liste übrig und ich finde das ist auch super übrigens ist auch toll der
zeigt dir hier an dass du das eigentlich viel besser machen kannst so und das ist doch wirklich
super easy es sollte eine navigations aus leiste mit top down sein ich ganz ehrlich ich bin da
nicht der große html profi aber wahrscheinlich würde ich navigations leiste mit top down nicht
so machen da würde ich mir weiß was am besten ist wenn du wenn du keine ahnung davon hast und
es relativ schnell gut aussehen soll würde ich mir ein fertiges css framework nehmen irgendwas
wie bootstrap oder so damit kriegt das dann jeder ganz gut hin aber ich bin halt nicht der große
java script und html css oder also top down habe ich dir ja gezeigt wie es funktioniert das
relativ einfach das kannst du auch für eine navigation im hintergrund irgendwie verwenden
aber wahrscheinlich willst du wahrscheinlich willst du eher so einen so einen so ein stylisches
hamburgermenü ja was gibt es für eine app die sowas hat in windows der taschenrechner vielleicht
ja du willst ob ich eher sowas oder du willst so ein stylisches hamburgermenü haben was ich
übrigens ernsthaft hamburgermenü nennt da würde ich ihnen fertiges css framework nehmen und gut
ist oder halt wenn man bisschen zeit hat sich selbst damit auseinandersetzen weil das sieht
natürlich dann immer immer individueller und letztendlich schöner aus man auch was dabei
gelernt findest du link gut ja link ist beste alter land link ist als der besten erfindung
überhaupt und die scharp war ist die scharp hat eh so ein paar sachen ist ein paar innovationen
gestartet die andere sprachen übernommen haben link ist eins davon diese ganze dependency
injection geschichte kommt ja auch aus dem dotnet umfeld gibt noch ein paar sachen also sie scharp
ist wirklich eine sprache die haben microsoft vor 15 jahren oder so haben sie damit angefangen
und das ist nicht quasi nach und nach kacke geworden und outdated geworden sondern sie
haben immer wieder was dran verbessert und zwar mit mit mit hirn ja das sind sachen die man die
man so über microsoft selten sagt aber das haben sie wirklich gut gemacht ja die haben es gab
erst letztens mit einer neuen version mit ein paar coolen syntaktischen sachen drin und man setzt
halt mit die scharp definitiv nicht auf das tote fährt das ist man muss sich überlegen was
gibt es für eine sprache die 15 jahre alt ist und in der beliebtheit jetzt wieder steigt noch
mehr ja dadurch dass er halt jetzt euch open source haben also das ist ja mir geht das aufgezwungene
objekt orientiert auf dem keks ist auch gar nicht mal so guck mal also wenn es also ich will jetzt
nicht sagen dass es jetzt die mega krasse funktionale geschichte ist ja aber es geht
auf jeden fall in die richtung und du kannst ja mal diese neue pattern matching geschichten
angucken im dies in der letzten scharp version gegeben hat und das ist richtig dass das das ist
wirklich geht jetzt geht schon in funktionale geschichten ja also man kann jetzt zum beispiel
sagen wie das ein gescheites beispiel einfällt keine ahnung switch test ist ein doofes beispiel
irgendwie ja ok sagen wir mal objekt irgendwie was weiß ich test hatte es dringend test drinne
wir wissen aber nicht dass es ein string ist sagen switch case mal gucken ob ich die neue
syntax aus dem kopf überhaupt hinkriege ist ne wie ging die neue pattern matching syntax
so
contains was weiß ich dann mach was also das geht das geht in die funktionale richtung jetzt
was microsoft in letzter zeit mit sie scharp macht und das ist voll im quasi im geister
zeit und eigentlich noch ziemlich coole geschichte würde java dafür nicht reichen dachte sie
scharp ist hardware basiert sorry für den repost falls du das nicht gesehen hast also
zwischen java und sie scharp ist im prinzip von der architektur wenig unterschied weder
java noch sie scharp sind sind also keine programmiersprache ist hardware du meinst
wahrscheinlich ist es quasi hardware näher wobei diese sache mit hardware nah das ist
auch so einen nicht wirklich ein bass wird sondern so was was jetzt immer drauf ankommt
wie man es verwendet die programmiersprache ist ja im endeffekt bloß in den syntax regelsatz
ja so wie was aussehen soll und ich kann auch zäh nehmen und wahrscheinlich in dort net
kompiliert oder so da muss nix hat wenn er es in dem sinn rauskommen weil man das bei
z sagt so ist es hart wenn er weil du so sachen machst wie wie rammer lockieren oder oder
irgendwie mit pointen rum schießen und so was aber sogar da ist es ja mittlerweile so
bei man neuerem c++ dass sogar die leute sagen hey du schießt ihr damit so oft selbst in den
fuß nehmen lieber irgendwelche standard nehmen wir sie standard reference standart pointer
irgendwas weiß gerade aus dem kopf nicht bei z plus buss und keine point das mehr also
das mit hardware da ist immer so eine sache oder wenn man sich mal rast anguckt zum beispiel
rast ist übelst war eigentlich aber trotzdem relativ angenehm und sicher also es ist immer
die frage was hinten raus fällt letztendlich und optimierten code kannst du ohne probleme
auch in der sprache wie sie schab raushauen oder in java sie schab ist es gibt einen benchmark
für web frameworks da ist sp dot net core auf dem nicht auf dem ersten aber auf dem
ersten platz wo vernünftige frameworks anfangen irgendwo hier wo ist mvc ich weiß nicht was
da alles dabei ist aber wenn man sich das hier anguckt sp dot net ist da ziemlich weit
vorne ich mein klar es ist ließ sich lahm aber das ist ein full feature web framework
ja mit datenbank mapper mit model view controller geschichten und alles wenn man sich anguckt
paar sachen sind hier noch davor aber die meisten sind halt so irgendwelche mini geschichten
und manche gauh sachen sind noch schneller aber letztendlich und wenn man halt die ganz
raw geschichte nehmt sp also quasi als bin eine core mit quasi mehr oder weniger von
hand gebastelt db axis bist du fast hast du fast eines der schnellsten web frameworks
die es gibt die sachen die davor sind sind irgendwelche minimal implementierungen die
nix können ohne da jetzt wegen einem zu nahe treten zu wollen und dann sieht man sie schab
kann auch brutal schnell sein es ist alles es ist immer nur die frage was hinten raus
fällt an code oder dem was letztendlich ausgeführt wird ja du kannst lahm scheiß c und c plus
plus sachen raus raus prügeln klar für manche anwendungs zweck geeignet sich das eine besser
als das andere das ist schon wahr ja aber scheiße kann man überall programmieren und
wenn ich finde mit sie scharfen vor allem wenn man windows sachen macht und mit dort
net core eigentlich auch alles ist das wirklich eine sache wenn setzt definitiv nicht auf
irgendwie ein totes pferd und man hat was wo man eigentlich noch jahre verwenden kann
also das eigentlich die beste sache wo man anfangen kann finde ich
was hältst du von rein als idee habe ich noch wenig verwendet kann ich nichts zu sagen
ja ja du kannst in diesen komischen link aber dings hier was hier zum demonstrieren
kratz man kann es dann auch mehr du kannst dann mehr machen du kannst nicht nur eine
sache machen du kannst ja auch einen kompletten funktions body aufmachen und dann dinger da
drinne treiben also das ist schon die gehen die funktionale
richtung was ist das hier das ist ein science and technology stream sagt witz warum heißt
das hamburger menü na weil es so aussieht wie den hamburger da guck was heißt also
falls ihr es nicht glaubt das heißt wirklich so
guck mal sogar wikipedia eintracht hat das ding das hamburger menü eiken
das ist link besser als die schrabe das einer mit dem anderen link ist teil vom dot net
framework kannst du in allen dot net sprachen verwenden unter anderem sie schaab link ist
keine programmier sprache also das sind zwei komplett verschiedene paar schuhe du kannst
link in sie schaab verwenden aber du kannst nicht sie schaab in link verwenden
ja da muss ich dir recht geben kuri mania es ist immer gut weil man ein bisschen übersicht
hat aber ich habe das gefühl die meisten leute haben eine sprache indem sie ihre sachen
am liebsten machen bei mir ist es die schaab und net und das sage ich als jemand der mit
linux sein geld verdient ja ich habe eigentlich mit microsoft gar nicht so viel am hut aber
dort net ist wirklich eine super plattform
aber es ist auf jeden fall sinnvoll weil man mehrere sachen kann also so eine kombination
aus ich sage es aber drei sachen wo ich denke das ganz praktisch ist wenn man so was kann
wie sie schaab dort net für backend geschichten ist nice und auch für windows desktop und
so was gepaart mit dem javascript html sonst war es frontend kram plus noch ein bisschen
shell bash im endeffekt das ist eine super kombination wo man rund um eigentlich eigentlich
klar kommt und auch relativ schnell sich andere sachen aneignen kann
type of cover in line assembly das hat jetzt noch gefehlt
mit rust habe ich auch ein bisschen rumgebastelt rust ist so eine typische sprache man wird
erst mal die ersten paar wochen wird man es hassen weil weil sich rust über jeden scheiß
anmeckert allerdings hat rust in der regel recht dass es verkehrt ist was du machst
wenn man sich so ein bisschen an diesen sonntags nie wie heißt das borrow checker wie heißt
das in rust screen monster borrow checker heißt es oder der guckt wer sich was geborgt hat
und wer was referenziert und so was wenn man da ein bisschen so denkt wie das quasi rust
macht dann ist rust eine coole sprache ja oxi das kann ich mir vorstellen ich bin jetzt
kein großer angular fan aber das liegt wahrscheinlich auch daran weil ich da zu wenig ahnung von
habe aber asp.net es ist wirklich das angenehmste web framework bisher was ich verwendet habe
ich habe lange zeit auf ruby geschwört also ruby und rails geschwört da dachte ich mir
ey beste aber das ist jetzt ja auch die letzten jahre ein bisschen abgekackt das einzige was
ich noch ein bisschen vermisse bei asp.net core ist das ist paar sachen im entity framework
aber im großen und ganzen ist das eine ganz tolle geschichte die microsoft sich da ausgedacht
hat und die legen ja auch ein bahnbrechendes tempo vor wo es da neue sachen gibt ich mein
gottnet core 3.0 ist um die ecke in gottnet core 3.0 wird es als erstes mal support geben
für wpf und winners anwendung und man kann ihn kann dann uwp zeugs darin verwenden also
das heißt vielleicht können wir demnächst uwp apps machen ohne scheiß winner store apps
machen zu müssen da bin ich mal gespannt darauf weil auf winner store apps hat ich kein mensch
irgendwie bock ne habt ihr auch nur eine winner store app installieren so moin leute jetzt
kommen jetzt so viele leute dabei eigentlich sind wir schon fertig warte immer noch auf
das geht total das haben wir das nicht mal gemacht das haben wir doch schon gemacht das
haben wir doch schon gemacht das ist immer schief drin 1 2 1 2 3 4 auf rust genau
weiß ich aber den gett grundlagen programmieren hier leute von wegen wir haben kein gett gett
tutorial gemacht nicht try gett gut sondern gett tutorial hier da ist es beim sebarro
immer schief ist es eine stunde 48 die seite die seite vom sebarro heißt allen ernstes
long as we waited now we debated da dann findest du visual basic easy ne nicht wirklich also
ich bin kein visual basic fan wenn dort net dann c sharp und c sharp ist der
oder
Die Frage hätte ich noch bei visual studio was müsste ich da unter neues
Projekt auswählen damit ich zum Beispiel das hello world anzeigen lassen
meinst du das ernst ist es jebait ich zeig dir das aber ich bin natürlich nicht
ob es jebait ist sagst einfach ganz normal bin aus desktop konsolen app so
und dann geht dann das hier auf man trägt sie hier einfach ganz easy ein hello twitch
und dann was du nicht vergessen darfst was viele tutorials vergessen du musst
ein read key oder read line oder sowas drunter machen weil wenn du das nicht
machst bleibt das konsolenfenster nicht auf sondern geht direkt wieder zu was
sagst du braucht man als voraussetzung dass man ausbildung als system integrator
machen kann also mit virtuellen maschinen und so weiter nix du musst
dich dafür interessieren und eine gute firma finden das geht ja nicht darum dass
du schon alles kannst du kannst es ja lernen wichtig ist eigentlich nur nicht
sich der kram interessiert erfahrung mit unity
ne nicht wirklich
also hauptsache also aber noch mal zur ausbildung ich denke das wichtigste ist
dass es einen interessiert wir haben viele azubis wurde das gefühl dass sie
haben juckt das null das natürlich immer ein bisschen blöd aber gut
letztendlich es kann auch nicht für jeden was sein aber wenn sie wenn es
sich interessiert ist eigentlich das wichtigste muss nichts können
wie stehst du zu cheats programmieren spricht nichts dagegen veröffentlichen
ist die ist die eigentliche sache wo ich mir überlegen würde ob ich machen
würde die seite ist dead welche seite du meinst das archiv das archiv das
vom sebaro das ist wahrscheinlich einfach überlastet weil kann mehr leute
draufgehen wie ist es nicht so schnell die seite
wir müssen dem sebaro mal auf twitch lasst mal alle dem sebaro auf twitter
schreiben dass das archiv aktualisiert werden muss
sebaro
was kann ich seine kauen fack jetzt ist was geschrieben
da ist er
muss ich mal schreiben kurz
okay normalen schluss ist als penz wieder auf die arbeit
na grundwissen ist ja das was für eine ausbildung lernst dafür ist die
ausbildung da genau dafür ist das also sollte man egal ob ausbildung oder
studium einfach interesse mit interesse ist das allerwichtigste bei so ziemlich
allem was man lernen will wenn ich was abfackt wirst du das nie lernen wenn du
heute sagst hey ich möchte richtig gut in keine ahnung zs go werden und ihr
macht das spiel kein spaß du wirst nicht gut werden du kannst nicht quälen dazu
du kannst sagen alter so jungs lass uns hinsetzen kommen spielen jetzt erst und
du wirst auch bis zu einem gewissen level kommen aber es wird dich übelst
abfacken und es wird dich an kotzen das game zehn stunden zu kreiten oder so
was in der richtung wohingegen du ein game hast was dir bock macht das ist ja
prinzip mit allem so hast du keine probleme zehn stunden zu kreiten
deswegen ist das wichtigste dass es dich interessiert und was noch gut ist wenn
es dazu kommt wenn man ein problem hat was man was ein nerven was man lösen
will das in kombination mit es interessiert ein sei ich das wichtigste
das ist das ist der krasseste jebait versuch oder ein schlechtes jebait
versuch den ich in letzter zeit gelesen haben es selbst in screen unity ist so
scheiße weil es passiert auf unity das ist so schlecht dass sein schon wieder
gut ist
morgen günnig
ok leute
alles da wir machen schluss outro musik wir sehen uns die tage macht es gut
im
Und das war's für heute.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Das war's für heute.
Copyright WDR 2021